Dann herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos die Folge Nr. 26.
Mit dem Gast Gaby Weber, eine investigative Journalistin, die sich unter anderem mit Argentinien beschäftigt, mit Mercedes-Benz in Argentinien, mit Eichmann und mit weiteren lustigen Geschichten, die wir hier der Reihe nach ansprechen wollen.
Ja, die Sendung ist ein bisschen eine Lektion in was ist dann eigentlich wirklich passiert in der Geschichte. Wir hatten ja in einer der vergangenen Folgen schon mal drüber geredet, wie man Geschichte interpretieren kann und wie groß der Unterschied zwischen den Dingen, die aufgeschrieben werden, die es in die Geschichtsbücher machen, die es in die Wikipedia oder die Tagesschau machen und dem was wirklich passiert ist. Und Gaby hat sich so ein bisschen offenbar dem verschrieben herauszufinden, was wirklich passiert ist.
Hallo Gaby.
Herzlich Willkommen.
Danke.
Ja, als Einführung die Geschichte von Gabys, dass sie Argentinien Korrespondentin ist, vom ARD, richtig? WDR?
Ja, von diversen Sender.
Und ursprünglich ging es um Mercedes-Benz, die unter der Diktatur von Betriebsräten die Babys entführt haben sollen. Eine ganz unglaubliche Geschichte, wie war das für dich?
Naja, ein bisschen komplizierter ist es. Es gab in Argentinien eine Militärdiktatur zwischen 1976 und 1983. Und da haben die großen Firmen, unter anderem Mercedes-Benz, Argentiner, die haben die Gunst der Stunde genutzt und haben die Betriebsräte, die bei ihnen Sabotage gemacht haben oder kürzere Arbeitszeiten oder mehr Freiräume oder irgendwie, also Nerven, das tun, was Gewerkschafter eigentlich tun sollten. Die einen Job gemacht haben. Und die haben sie dann als Terroristen den Militärs verfiffen. Und damit ist irgendwie klar, was dann passiert ist. Die haben sie dann zu Hause abgeholt, haben sie durchgefoltert und haben sie dann aus Flugzeugen in den Fluss geworfen. Und die sind bis heute verschwunden, insgesamt 14. Im Rahmen dieser Recherchen ist mir dann aufgefallen, dass die Manager dieser, von Mercedes-Benz, aber auch von anderen deutschen Firmen, nämlich von Bayer, auch die Gunst der Stunde genutzt haben und sich Babys unter den Nagel gerissen haben. Also während der Militärdiktatur sind ja auch schwangere Regime-Gegnerinnen verhaftet worden. Und das war am Anfang sehr kompliziert, weil die wurden natürlich erstmal gefoltert und dann haben mehrere von diesen schwangeren Gefangenen auch ihr Baby verloren, wegen der Folter. Ich möchte darauf verzichten, euch zu beschreiben, wie sowas abgeht. Und dann ist die katholische Kirche, die ging ja ein und aus in den Folterzentren und die haben dann gesagt, naja, dass ihr hier die Terroristen foltert und dann ermordet, das ist ja okay, aber das ist das ungeborene Leben, das ist nicht okay. Das gilt es zu retten. Und dann ist sozusagen auf deren Initiative hin hat man dann durchgesetzt, dass die Frauen erstmal nicht gefoltert werden, dass sie entweder einen Kaiserschnitt kriegen oder ihr Kinder auf die Welt bringen können. Dann hat man ihnen die Babys weggenommen, sie wurden dann auch getötet und die Babys landeten dann in Familien von entweder hohen Militärs, aber eben auch von Managern von Großunternehmen, eben Mercedes-Benz, Bayer und und und. Und da gibt es eben mehrere Fälle von Mercedes-Benz. Und in dem Fall bin ich auch Nebenklägerin.
Also wenn ich sowas höre, denke ich ja, das klingt so weit hergeholt. Wie kommt man denn überhaupt dazu, sich mit so einem Fall zu beschäftigen? Also klingt das nicht auch, wenn man zum ersten Mal die Anschuldigung hört, schon so derartig unglaublich, dass man da die Finger von lässt? Ich meine, wie bist du zu dem Fall gekommen überhaupt? Also war das deine Initiative oder haben dich die angesprochen, die Nachfahren der Opfer? Oder was für Papiere gibt es überhaupt zu sowas? Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass da irgendjemand was aufhebt, nach solchen Greultaten.
Ja, das dachten wir auch alle. Aber es gibt ja doch sehr viel Archive immer noch. Es kommt immer noch was raus. Also das Thema der Menschenrechte ist in Argentinien in aller Munde. Und das ist ganz wichtig für die Gesellschaft. Das ist ja jetzt, ja 1983 wurde das wieder demokratisch. Und jetzt, dann gab es Amnestie-Gesetze. Die gibt es seit fast zehn Jahren eben nicht mehr. Und seitdem laufen Prozesse in Argentinien. Wobei es sehr schwierig ist, wenn man wirklich sich um die wirtschaftliche Macht kümmert. Das ist ja in Deutschland auch nicht anders gewesen. Nach 1945, man hat also hier SS-Leute, Leute aus den Konzentrationslagern. Die hat man dann sehr, sehr lange Zeit später hat man angefangen, diese Leute zu verfolgen. Aber ich meine, Herr Abst, damals deutsche Bank während des Krieges, den haben die Militärs noch, die Alliierten, vor Gericht gestellt. Aber dann wurde er rechter Hand von Adenauer. Und gerade Adenauer hat ja seine Macht auf diese Leute basiert. Also damals waren in der Bundesrepublik, waren alle Behörden, die Repressionsbehörden, sowieso aber auch die deutsche Wirtschaft voller Nazis. Und in Argentinien ist das eigentlich nicht unbedingt viel anders. Also die Repressionsbehörden, die werden jetzt gesäubert. Aber in der Wirtschaft ja, das ist eben schwierig. Und die sagen, wir haben ja nicht selbst gemordet. Wir haben eben nur gesagt, wer diese Leute sind. Und dieses Unternehmen, also in diesem Fall Mercedes-Benz oder Daimler, die Daimler AG, vertuscht eben, soweit es geht, alles. Aber es gibt schon noch Dokumente. Also das ist gar nicht die Frage.
Welche Art von Beweisführung kann man überhaupt führen bei solchen Verfahren, die 40 Jahre zurückliegen, 50 Jahre? Also ich meine, gibt es da überhaupt noch? Selbst wenn du sagst, es gibt da noch Akten, die man irgendwo finden kann. Das kann ja schon mal nicht einfach sein, die überhaupt zu finden. Und wenn man die dann hat, ist das nicht alles ehe verjährt? Also ich meine, ich stimme das nicht so einfach vor, jetzt irgendwelche Firmen zu belangen, die es in der Zwischenzeit vielleicht gar nicht mehr gibt sogar, weil die irgendwie zugemacht haben oder verstaatlicht wurden wegen anderer Missetaten.
Wir reden ja nicht von der Mafia, wir reden von Großunternehmen.
Die Unterschiede können fließend sein.
Ja, die Methoden und die Ethik ist sehr ähnlich, um nicht zu sagen fast identisch. Aber die innere Logik ist natürlich eine völlig andere. Also die müssen schon Rechenschaft ablegen, die müssen Steuererklärung machen. Da gibt es Angestellte, die werden sozial versichert, da weiß man wer die sind, wann die Arbeitsverhältnisse aufgehört haben. Ist dann schon merkwürdig. Ich habe ja die Unterlagen, die haben die Verschwundenen noch 10 Jahre lang als Arbeiter geführt und auch noch die Löhne weiter gezahlt, weil sie Angst hatten, dass sonst die Witwinder auf die Barrikaden steigen. Also man kann eine ganze Menge machen. Es gibt ja die Überlebenden noch. Von den Betriebsräten haben ja drei auch überlebt. Die sind gefoltert worden. Die haben Aussagen gemacht vor argentinischen Gerichten, auch vor deutschen Gerichten. Und zur Frage der Verjährung, das sind ja nicht einfache Straftaten. Also in Argentinien verjährt, ich glaube, Mord verjährt auch nach 20 Jahren. In Deutschland verjährt Mord gar nicht.
Mehr, das ist auch eine Sache erst nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg.
Ja, in den 60er Jahren wurde das erst geändert wegen der Nazis. Aber wir reden ja hier von Verbrechen gegen die Menschheit, Crimes against humanity. Das wird in Deutschland leider immer falsch übersetzt mit Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit, muss man irgendwie auch mal richtig übersetzen. Also das sind ganz schlimme Straftaten, die nicht verjähren. Und insofern kann man da immer noch die Beweise suchen und auch finden. Ich will dir ein Beispiel erzählen. Wir haben immer gedacht, es muss irgendwo das Geheimarchiv der Militärs sein. Vor allem, was die Babys angeht, weil da sind die Menschenrechtsgruppen, schätzende sind noch, insgesamt sind 500 Babys den Regimegegnerinnen weggenommen worden und anderen Leuten gegeben worden. Davon sind 105 inzwischen aufgeklärt. Die haben ihre wahre Identität inzwischen wieder erlangt. Fast alle, diese Fälle sind fast alle dadurch entstanden, in dem sie selbst Zweifel hatten, dass ihre Eltern wirklich ihre richtigen Eltern sind und die dann von sich aus einen Gentest verlangt haben. So, und wir suchten immer danach und ich habe dann schon, das war 2005, habe ich die Geburtsurkunden von dem Daimler-Manager Juan Ronaldo Tasselkraut und von seinem Bruder bei der Justiz eingereicht. Der Tasselkraut war auch der Manager, der auch die Betriebsräte der Militärs ausgeliefert hat. Und er hat in seiner Familie drei Kinder, von denen ich meine, inzwischen auch weiß und beweisen kann, zumindest von zwei, dass sie in Folterzentren auf die Welt gekommen sind. Also 2004 konnte ich das noch nicht beweisen, hatte ich nur einen Verdacht und habe die Geburtsurkunden, die ich über das Standesamt mir besorgt habe, bei der Justiz eingereicht. Und habe gesagt, pass auf, hier sind die Geburtsurkunden, da steht drinnen zwei Tasselkrautbabys, sind dann und dann während der Diktatur in einer Hausgeburt geboren worden. Das ist also sehr unüblich, Hausgeburten. Also auch Leute, die kein Geld haben, gehen in öffentliche Hospitäler und bringen da ihre Kinder zur Welt. Und die Hebammen, die dort unterschrieben haben, die sind in x andere Fälle von Menschenrechtsverletzungen verwickelt und außerdem wussten die Kinder und haben das in der Schule erzählt, dass sie adoptiert sind. Hier sind sie als biologische Kinder eingetragen. So, dann wussten sie, das war jetzt das Jahr 2004, wussten sie erst nicht, was machen sie damit. Die wollten das natürlich nicht weiterverfolgen. Mercedes-Benz produziert in Argentinien noch. Da gibt es auch noch Arbeitsplätze und, und, und. Dann haben sie drei Jahre fast gar nichts gemacht. Dann haben sie einen Prozess gemacht, wo sie dann auch die Kinder, also inzwischen sind das 30-jährige Männer, vorgeladen haben. Und die haben gesagt, ja, wir wussten ja immer, dass wir adoptiert waren. Und da haben die Richter gesagt, okay, dann sind zwar diese Geburtserkunden gefälscht, aber das ist dann verjährt. Wir sprechen diese Leute frei. Und das einzige, was sie ermittelt haben, ich habe mir dann die Akte geholt. Das kann ich ja als Nebenklägerin, das ist der Vorteil. Und stelle fest, die einzigen Ermittlungshandlungen, die die Staatsanwalt vorgenommen hatte, war, sie haben geguckt, ob die von mir angereichten Geburtserkunden auch echt waren. Dann haben sie beim Standesamt angefragt und merkwürdigerweise auch bei einer Behörde, die nennt sich Nationales Register für Personen, wäre hier in Deutschland vielleicht die Meldep-Behörde. Also eine polizeiinterne Behörde. Und haben da auch nochmal gefragt, wie ist das, habt ihr eine Geburtserkunde? Und beim Standesamt kamen genau dasselbe, was ich auch schon angereicht hatte, aber das Meldep-Amt hat eine Geburtserkunde vorgelegt. Ich dachte, ja, das sind die Tasselkrautkinder, aber keine Hausgeburt, sondern da stand irgendeine Adresse drin in San Martin, die kannte ich nicht. Und dann habe ich Freunde vorbeigeschickt und die haben gesagt, aha, das ist die Militärakademie, eins der berüchtigsten Folterzentren während der Militärdiktatur. Das heißt, die hatten auch ihre Eichmänner, die ganz sorgfältig ihre Bücher geführt haben und gesehen haben, in den eigenen Büchern müssen wir natürlich reinschreiben, was gewesen ist. Und das sind Urkunden, das sind riesige Register und da ist jetzt alles eingetragen. Also man kann heute sagen, die Beweise liegen auf dem Tisch, die Babys vom Bruder des Mercedes-Manager Tasselkrauts sind in einem Folterzentrum zur Welt gekommen. Auf dieser Grundlage sind sie freigesprochen worden. Und die Firma Daimler hüllt sich in peinliche Schweigen und sagt dazu nichts.
Also die Ermittlung klingt jetzt für mich eher so, als wenn ihr versucht habt, ein Verfahren abzuwehren, als wenn es darum gegangen wäre, da tatsächlich irgendwas zu ermitteln.
Ne, die wollten natürlich nicht ermitteln. Wie gesagt, sie haben nur ein bisschen da rumgeguckt, ob sie mir was ans Bein binden können, um zu gucken, hat sie vielleicht da selbst was gefälscht. Das war das Einzige. Ansonsten haben sie die von vornherein freisprechen wollen.
Kann man das allgemein so sagen, bei Sachen, die du recherchierst, dass die eigentlich eher gegen dich arbeiten, die Gerichte, als für die Gerechtigkeit? Und wenn du damit irgendwie peinlichen Sachen kommst, dass die dann... oder ist die Justiz... Also kann man irgendwie so ein Restglauben an die Justiz aufrechterhalten, würde ich wissen, dass man sagt, naja, so, aber im Gro, arbeiten die schon integer und es lohnt sich überhaupt, so ein Verfahren zu machen.
Man muss da sehr genau hingucken. Also wir haben jetzt über die argentinische Justiz geredet. In Argentinien finden im Moment Verfahren statt gegen Folterer. Eben, das sind auch diese Brutalo-Typen, die in den Konzentrationslagern waren oder die die Einsatzbefehle gegeben haben, irgendwelche Generäle. Diese Verfahren finden statt, da gibt es auch politischen Willen. Eine andere Sache ist, wenn es wirklich um ganz viel Geld geht, in Argentinien hast du noch das Problem, dass die Leute einfach auch korrupt sind. Also da gibt es wirklich Leute, ich kenne Anwälte und die haben mir das erzählt, da gibt es Leute, die gehen mit einem Geldkoffer dahin und da wird es so geregelt. Das ist sicher nicht der Fall in Deutschland.
Das gibt es bei der CDU auch gelegentlich.
Ist mir bei der Recherche aber noch nicht in Deutschland über den Weg gelaufen. Kann sein. Und in den USA wird das auch anders geregelt. In Deutschland war es völlig unmöglich. Die Anzeigen sind ja alle vorhergestellt worden in Deutschland. Sowohl gegen Tasselkraut, wegen Mordes, den Betriebsräten, Mithilfe, Beihilfe zum Mord, als eben auch wegen der Babys. Und die deutsche Justiz hat die Verfahren, also wegen der Babys, gar nicht erst eröffnet, weil sie gesagt haben, die Kinder möchten das nicht. Und im Fall von den Verschwundenen haben sie dann ein bisschen rum ermittelt und nach drei Jahren gesagt, ach ja, wir können ja gar nicht beweisen, dass die Verschwundenen wirklich tot sind. Vielleicht kommen sie ja irgendwann mal wieder und sind wieder da.
Wie die Ausrede war nicht, dass es in Argentinien war, sondern, also das hätte ich jetzt vermutet, dass sie sagen, wir sind nicht zuständig, weil die Verbrechen auf Argentinischen...
Nö, die Firma ist ja eine deutsche Firma und der Tasselkraut ist auch deutscher Staatsbürger.
Aha. Und wie kamst du jetzt von diesen Verbrechen während der Militärdiktatur und den Daimler-Managern zu Eichmann?
Dazwischen liegt noch eine andere Station. Also ich hab dann irgendwann mal, hat mich das, ich muss echt sagen, ich werd oft gefragt, was mich da so motiviert, warum ich mich da so festgebissen habe, in der Wade von dieser Firma. Ihr müsst euch einfach mal vorstellen, wir sind dann also mit Leuten aus Argentinien auch zu den Hauptversammlungen gegangen, zu Daimler, hier im ICC, wo dann 10.000 Aktieninhaber sitzen. Von den 10.000 sind 50 wichtig, das sind dann Fonds, vielleicht redet da von Fondsgesellschaften und so. Alle anderen gehen dahin, weil man kriegt man umsonst Würstchen und so. Die wollen sich dann mal diese Pappnasen aus der Nähe ansehen. Und ihr müsst euch einfach mal diese Fressen von diesen Leuten ansehen, mit was für einer Selbstgerechtigkeit, die da oben sitzen und einfach sagen, ihr könnt uns alle mal. Also du kommst dann immer mit dem Gefühl raus, die bis heute nehmen sie sich das Recht raus, Leute als Terroristen anzuschwerzen, die ihnen nicht in den Kram passen und foltern und ermorden zu lassen. Wenn die von Anfang an, also meine erste Geschichte ist im Jahr 1999. Das ist jetzt vor, Kopfrechnung, warte mal, 13 Jahren. Wenn die irgendwie mal im zweiten Jahr oder so, wenn sie gesehen haben, das Ding läuft noch, wir setzen uns jetzt mal hin, wir entschuldigen uns, wir sagen, wir haben vielleicht nicht genug getan, wir gucken, wer ist da noch überleben, können wir da noch was machen, dafür müssen sie nicht mal in ihre Portugase greifen und dann hätten sie irgendwie ein bisschen Zerknirschung gezeigt und sich ein bisschen entschuldigt, dann wäre das Ding, glaube ich, gar nicht so groß geworden. Aber einfach diese Fressen zu sehen und diese Selbstgerechtigkeit, die genau wissen, sie können auf die große Presse, können sie sich verlassen, im Wesentlichen über natürlich die Anzeigen, sie sind einer der größten Anzeigenkunden überhaupt und die Bundesregierung wird natürlich nichts tun, was eine deutsche Traditionsfirma irgendwie in die Klemme geraten lässt und die Justiz, naja, die Erfahrung in Deutschland ist, diese Verfahren waren nicht möglich in Deutschland zu eröffnen. Insofern ist das eigentlich fast die größte Motivation, die ich so hatte. Aber zurück zu deiner Frage, was kam danach? Danach kam, ich habe dann die Geschichte der Firma, mich drum gekümmert, und Mercedes-Benz Argentinen, wie kamen die da überhaupt dahin? Das weiß man hier ja auch nicht. Die sagen immer, Deutschland, deutsche Auslandsinvestition 1951, einer der ersten Auslandsinvestitionen nach dem Krieg und alles wunderbar. Na ja, wenn man da ein bisschen anfängt zu gucken, ist richtig, die sind 1951 gegründet worden in Argentinien, zu Zeiten mit enger Zusammenarbeit vom General Juan Domingo Perón. Und das Glück dabei ist, die sind 1955 beschlagnahmt worden, die ganze Firma. Und ist dichtgemacht worden bis 1969. Und dann kam raus, es war eine riesige Geldwaschanlage von Nazi-Geldern, die die während des Zweiten Weltkrieges aufgrund von guten Geschäften, die sie mit Nazi-Regimen machen konnten, oder mit der Zwangsarbeit, oder mit sonst irgendwie Deals, haben die gebunkert und haben die dann wieder über das Dreiecksgeschäft über Argentinien gewaschen sozusagen.
Kannst du mal erklären, wie das lief? Also wie der Mechanismus hinter dieser Geldwäsche war?
Das ist eine ganz komplizierte Geschichte gewesen. Ich sag dir vielleicht vorher noch eins. Es gab damals, sie sind 55 beschlagnahmt worden beim Putsch gegen Pyrronen und dann haben die damals, war eine Militärputsch war das, und dann haben die gesagt, das ist ein riesen Korruptionsding gewesen, wir klären das jetzt auf. Und es gab dann auch eine parlamentarische Untersuchungskommission zu Daimler und die Staatsanwaltschaft hat ermittelt, wegen Geldwäsche, Korruption und und und. Und diese Dokumente, die waren die ganze Zeit weg. Die gab es einfach nicht. Und die habe ich noch 2002, 2003 gefunden. Richtig, mit der Brechstange in der Hand bin ich da eingebrochen. Neben mir war die die Chefin vom Bundesarchiv, vom Argentinischen. Da haben wir der Schlösser aufgebrochen, wo diese Akten lagen und die durfte ich damals einsehen und kopieren und auswerten. Also das, was ich sage, basiert auf diesen Dingen. Darüber habe ich auch ein Buch geschrieben und Daimler hat das nicht dementiert. Im Gegenteil. Damals haben sie mich noch in ihr Archiv gelassen.
Heute nicht mehr.
Zu den ganzen Geschichten zu den Babys und zu den Verschwundenen sagen sie, da läuft ein Verfahren in den USA, das möchten wir jetzt abwarten, da möchten wir sie nicht reinlassen.
Aber das läuft ja auch wegen dir, oder? Zumindest mit deiner...
Das geht um Dinge, die ich recherchiert habe und ich habe den Familienangehörigen sehr zugeredet, dieses Verfahren in den USA zu eröffnen.
Wie kommen denn die USA überhaupt in diese Sache rein?
Ich kann nur mal den Faden, weil sonst fahre ich nicht mehr. Okay, also wir waren bei der Geldwäsche.
Bei der Geldwäsche. Die haben ab 1951, haben die, das war zu Zeiten von Perron, mit einer ganz strikten Devisenkontrolle, da ist jeder Peso, der in das Land reingekommen ist, oder Dollar oder D-Mark oder Schweizer Franken, total erfasst worden. Aber irgendwie kamen dann die Daimler-Manager, ich kenne auch die Flüge, ich weiß mit welchen Flugzeugen die kamen, mit der Flugnummer, mit den Schiffen, mit den Frachtern, kamen die an, haben in Montevideo, das ist in Uruguay direkt gegenüber, auf dem Schwarzmarkt, da ist keine Devisenkontrolle, war auch nie, haben sie zum günstigen Kurs getauscht, kamen zurück und haben damit insgesamt 65 riesige Aktiengesellschaften aufgekauft. Und zwar meistens mit Cash. Na ja, eigentlich immer mit Cash.
Und das war Geld, was sie irgendwie, wo hatten sie das gebunkert, also wo kam das her?
Das kann man nur vermuten, die Flüge ging immer aus der Schweiz.
Oh, okay, praktischerweise.
Gut, das macht Sinn, ja.
Ja, und sie bestreiten das hier auch alle nicht. Und es gibt ja dann auch Zeugenaussagen ihrer eigenen Mitarbeiter, die sagen, so ist das eben dann gewaschen worden. Dann haben die investiert, nicht nur im Bergbau, sie haben natürlich auch diese Automobilfirma, in die Lastwagenfirma investiert. Sie haben vor allem in der Flugzeugindustrie, sie haben also das halbe Land damit aufgekauft und haben dann auch zum Beispiel auch Lebensmittel wieder ins Nachkriegsdeutschland exportiert und haben sozusagen über dieses Dreiecksgeschäft, Export, Import, haben sie dann schlicht und einfach Geld gewaschen. Sie haben eine doppelte Buchführung gemacht, die habe ich auch, die schwarze Buchführung, können sie also gar nichts bestreiten, und haben eben auch überhöhte Rechnungen gestellt um diesen Geldfluss zu legitimieren. Und das ist irgendwann mal, weil die Konkurrenz sich darüber natürlich geärgert hat, dass immer bei allen Ausschreibungen die Deutschen dann gewinnen, weil sie unterbieten, ist das mit dem Putsch gegen Perron, ist es dann aufgeflogen und ist dann auch untersucht worden. Und dann haben sie erst 1959, haben sie wieder ihre Pforten eröffnen können. Da gab es eine Arbeit, da haben sie wieder Leute eingestellt und einer davon war Ricardo Clement, alias Adolf Eichmann. Der ist als Elektriker, hat er dann einen Job gekriegt.
Okay, und wie kamst du dann zu dem?
Ja, nach der Geldwäsche.
Also wie kommt man jetzt immer gut Geldwäsche? Das ist ja so ein großes Thema. Und dann bist du zufällig darüber gestolpert, dass sie den eingestellt haben?
Also ich habe im Rahmen dieser Geldwäsche-Geschichten, in dem Fall hat mir auch die Argentinische Regierung, das war noch 2003, 2004, da war Kirchner noch, Dr. Nester Kirchner, das war eine gute Zeit. Und die hatten am Anfang, heute machen sie auch, vertuschen sie auch alles. Aber damals waren die noch ganz offen für solche Recherchen. Und dann haben sie mir zum Beispiel, ich wollte wissen, wer da gearbeitet hat, und ich habe die gesamten Sozialversicherungsbelege. Wer da jemals gearbeitet hat bei Mercedes-Benz, ich habe bis 1972 oder so. Und das waren alles Nazis. Also vor allem die obere, die Chef-Etage, das waren alles Nazis aus Deutschland. Die kamen auch nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Bei vielen Weichsicht, bei ganz vielen Vermutigkeits, die sind mit falschen Papieren gekommen, mussten auch untertauchen. Und das war dann klar, dass das auch, sagen wir mal, ein Unternehmen war, wo auch Leute, die weg mussten, die untergetaucht sind aus Deutschland, also Nazis, die belastet waren, und erstmal eine Zeit lang untertauchen wollten, weil die wollten ja dann wieder in den 60er Jahren zurückkommen, erstmal untergetaucht sind bei Mercedes-Benz in Argentinien. Und eben einer davon war dann Adolf Eichmann. Und natürlich habe ich am Anfang das geglaubt, was alle geglaubt haben, das, was der Mozart in Büchern noch und noch erzählt, dass der Mozart 1960 Adolf Eichmann in einer heroischen Aktion nach einer jahrelangen Suche in Argentinien entführt haben will und nach Israel ausgeflogen haben will. Und die Geschichte stimmt so nicht. Also wenn man mal anfängt, die Sache so ein bisschen hochzuheben, die stimmt hinten und vorne nicht. Und die stimmt dies auch ganz schlecht eigentlich zurechtgebogen. Deshalb, ich kriege ja öfters den Vorwurf einer Verschwörungstheoretikerin, dass, wenn das eine Verschwörung gewesen wäre, dann hätten die das richtig gut eingefädelt. Aber es stimmt, also praktisch stimmt es nicht. Also der Moss hat zum Beispiel sagt, sie haben Eichmann mit dem Flugzeug, mit LAL, einer Bristol Britannia von Buenos Aires, mit einem Zwischenstopp in Dakar direkt nach Israel geflogen. Ja, dann guckst du die Britannia dir an. Die hat auf dem Hinflug in Brasilien einen Zwischenstopp zum Auftanken gemacht. Fragst du den Hersteller, kann die überhaupt so weit fliegen? Sagen die, nein, das kann die gar nicht. Das heißt, die mussten irgendwo in Brasilien zwischen landen. Es geht nicht anders. Es sei denn, sie hätten eine Luftbetankung gemacht oder...
Das ist wahrscheinlich für diesen Flugzeugtyp gar nicht gibt.
Ja, nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Also ist aber auch egal. Auf jeden Fall stimmt hinten und vorne nicht. Und da muss also ganz viel gelaufen sein. Was eher auf eine richtige Improvisation hindeutet, als auf eine richtige Verschwörung.
Okay, es gibt noch zwei Punkte, die wir jetzt kurz am Rande übersprungen haben, die ich aber sehr wichtig finde. Erstens, die Nazis in Argentinien rechneten fest damit, dass sie demnächst nach Deutschland zurückkehren können würden, weil ihre Straftaten verjähren würden. Ja, also das habe ich vorhin schon kurz erwähnt, dass Mord keine Verjährung hat in Deutschland. Das war damals noch nicht so, sondern die die Nazi-Verbrechen, das war Beihilfe zum Mord. Nach 15 Jahren wäre das verjährt gewesen und Mord selbst 20 Jahre. Das wäre 1960 bzw. 1965 gewesen. Das heißt, die Nazis haben gedacht, sie müssen in Argentinien jetzt die paar Jahre halt überbrücken und kommen dann zurück nach Deutschland und regieren in Ruhe weiter. Also das war der Plan. Und das hat mir so in der Schule keiner erzählt. Also das fand ich eine starke Einsicht. An der Stelle. Die hat mich auch echt umgehauen, überhaupt die Stirn zu haben. Wir machen dann einfach weiter.
Ja, aber das ist ganz wichtig, dass du das erwähnst, weil wir heute, wir kennen den Internationalen Strafgerichtshof. Wir reden von Verbrechen gegen die Menschheit. Wir reden, dass man diese Leute verfolgt. Ein paar Leute sind ja dann auch verfolgt worden. Das war eben damals völlig anders. Und gerade eben der Adenauer Staat, der CDU-Stadt, der 50er Jahre, der wusste eben nicht, aha, kommen diese Leute zurück, fordern hier ein, die werden auch wieder in die Parteien zurückgehen. Selbst wenn wir es schaffen, weil das die Amerikaner wollten, hier keine neue Nazi-Partei zuzulassen. Aber die FDP war voller Nazis zum Beispiel. Die hat die mit offenen Armen aufgenommen. Und die anderen Parteien jetzt nicht so sehr wie die FDP, aber auch die Medien. Wir können ja auch mal über den Nazis in den Medien reden. Beim BND wissen wir das und beim BKA. Aber in den Medien darüber reden wir eigentlich immer weniger. Aber da hat es ja auch diese Leute gegeben. Und wer war denn der Spiegel-Korrespondent in Südamerika? Das war der langjährige engste Mitarbeiter von Herrn Goebbels gewesen, nämlich Winfried von Ofen. Und da hat Herr Rudolf Augstern persönlich seinen Presseausweis unterschrieben. Also die ganze Spiegel-Redaktion, die Auslandsredaktion vom Spiegel war durchsessen. Das ist jetzt ein Medium. Die anderen waren nicht anders. Also und man wusste eben auch nicht, was kommt, die kommen zurück und wie wären denn die verwaltungsgerichtlichen Prozesse ausgegangen, wenn die ihre Karriere wieder hätten restituieren, also wiederherstellen wollen. Wäre das Beamtenrecht zum Tragen gekommen? Ich vermute mal ja. Dann wären die wieder auf ihre Posten. Die hatten ja kein Verfahren, kein Strafverfahren, also hätte die Unschuldsvermutung gegolten. Es war auch alles verjährt, man hätte das nicht mehr aufgemacht. Spielt das mal durch, was da auch hätte passieren können, wie dann die Bundesrepublik oder wie überhaupt Westeuropa ausgesehen hätte, mit diesen Leuten in den hohen Positionen wieder. Das war aber der...
Ein Alptraum, ja.
Ja, aber das war das Ziel.
Diese Entscheidung, den Mord und Kriegsverbrechen halt nicht verjährend zu machen, wer hat die denn dann getroffen?
Das habe ich irgendwie die Tage recherchiert in der Wikipedia und das läuft unter dem Stichwort Sternstunde des Parlamentarismus.
Das ist die andere große Mossad-Lüge.
Was ich so derartig obs Zöhnen fand, wenn man sich das dann nämlich durchguckt, das war nicht so, dass sie gesagt haben, das verliert jetzt mal nicht, sondern die haben erst gesagt, das würde demnächst verjähren, machen wir mal fünf Jahre länger, weil die Bundesrepublik, die hat ja erst 1949 richtig angefangen. Also zumindest die Zeit sollten wir das verschieben, dann haben die das verschoben. Wie üblich in der Politik, dann ist die Zeit um gewesen, ohne dass irgendjemand verfolgt wurde, dann heißt es naja, machen wir noch mal fünf Jahre. Also so ging es ja, das war so eine Salamitaktik. Keineswegs der moralische Aufschrei und so, wir müssen jetzt hier mal, wir machen das jetzt mal richtig. So überhaupt nicht. Und es gab lange Debatten, ob man das überhaupt machen kann oder nicht, weil juristisch eben die Frage im Raum stand, ob man überhaupt Leute verfolgen kann, wenn nach dem ursprünglich zu dem verbrechenszeitpunktgültigen Gesetz das jetzt verjährt wäre. Also da gab es dann auch so diese Anwälte, diese Leute, so Juristen, wie der Glopke, die heute die Vorratsdatenspeicherung juristisch verargumentieren. Diese Art von, also furchtbar, die da also Rabulistik betrieben haben, ob man es jetzt so oder so machen kann oder nicht. Also das war überhaupt nicht klar, dass es so ausgehen würde, sondern erst nachdem das eine große Debatte in Deutschland losging zu der Frage, hat sich das dann so entschieden. Und über zehn Jahre lief diese Debatte. Das war nicht... wir machen das jetzt mal eben.
Da gibt es noch eine ganz kleine Anekdote dazu. Führt jetzt ein bisschen von Eichmann ab, aber führt wieder zum Mossad hin. Es gab... der Mossad... Israel sagt, ja, es ist richtig, in 60er Jahren, das hat sich sehr lange hingezogen, diese Diskussion. Die SPD wollte diese Verjährung unbedingt aufheben und die war dahinter. Und dann gab es 1965, gab es auch so eine Geschichte vom Mossad, wo sie in Montevideo auch so angeblich so Nazi hingerichtet haben. Also da haben sie einen hingerichtet, ein angeblichen lettischen Nazi, auf dessen Konto auch sehr viele Morde gehen sollen. Ich habe die Geschichte dann im jüdischen Museum in Riga mal recherchiert, weil der Mossad hat da auch wieder etliche Bücher schreiben lassen zu und keiner hat protestiert. Da haben alle gedacht, oh, das ist wieder so ein wichtiges historisches Dokument. Also im jüdischen Museum in Riga haben sie gesagt, das ist eine ganz große Pille-Palle. Da hätten sie dem Mossad schon ein bisschen mehr zugetraut. Aber sowas läuft dann. Sie pucken irgendwas hin und glauben, ja, die Leute nehmen das dann irgendwie zur Kenntnis. Ich persönlich finde es gut, dass diese Dinge nicht verjähren, weil die Sachen sind so schlimm, dass sie schon weiter verfolgt werden müssen. Hat aber einen negativen, trotzdem eine negative Konsequenz. Wenn die Sachen nicht irgendwann mal zu Ende sind, reden die Leute bis an ihr Lebensende nicht. Das ist sozusagen ein bisschen schade, dass auch von den ganzen alten Nazis im Grunde nie jemand, nie jemals jemand ausgepackt hat.
Das hat die selbe Argumentation, die auch gegen den internationalen Strafgericht gebracht wird, dass gesagt wird, okay, wenn die Leute keinen Ausweg haben, also wenn es halt irgendwie keine Verjährung, keine irgendwie geartete Möglichkeit gibt, dann raus noch irgendwie rauszukommen oder irgendwie einfach auszupacken, dann tun sie es halt auch nicht, sondern halten halt den Mund und gehen in den Untergrund. Und auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich sagen, wie das Argument halt für die Gerechtigkeit überwiegt. Also es ist halt eine interessante Frage. Also man hat lieber Aufklärung, hat man lieber Gerechtigkeit oder kann es überhaupt Gerechtigkeit ohne eine gründliche Aufklärung geben? Das ist natürlich auch so ein spannendes moralisches Dilemma, was sich da aufspannt.
Ja, aber wenn es doch um Aufklärung geht, dann könnte man doch einfach mal sagen, dass zum Beispiel alle staatlichen Archive doch geöffnet werden müssen in diesen Fällen. Aber das Gegenteil ist doch der Fall. Also wir reden jetzt von Eichmann. Ich habe ja dann irgendwann mal, als ich dann gemerkt habe, das ist jetzt vier Jahre her, dass diese ganze Eichmann Geschichte von hinten und vorne einfach nicht stimmt, habe ich dann gedacht, okay, ich will jetzt mal vom BND wissen. Die haben ja auch eine ganze Menge von Nazis von Anfang an immer gehabt und habe dann eine Anfrage gemacht. Und der BND, das muss wohl die erste Anfrage gewesen sein, hat sich damals so selbstsicher gefühlt, dass ich, also ich wollte wissen über Adolf Eichmann und die nukleare Zusammenarbeit zwischen der Bundesrepublik Israel und Argentinien. Und dann haben die mir da wirklich einen Brief zurückgeschrieben und haben gesagt, ja, Frau Weber, wir haben das, was sie suchen, viereinhalbtausend Blatt und wir werden das nie rausgeben und ihnen sowieso nicht.
Das ist ja total bescheuert ist, zuzugeben, dass sie das überhaupt haben.
Naja, der BND hat nicht die hellsten Köpfe, das wissen wir ja. Das war natürlich ein großer Fehler, weil dachte ich mir, das ist ja schön, jetzt werde ich das mal...
Ist ja so ein bisschen so ein Lockköder, ich esse die Karotte.
Das gucken wir jetzt mal. Und dann bin ich zu Gericht gegangen, zum Bundesverwaltungsgericht und habe das klären lassen. Erstens haben sie dann gesagt, ja, von den viereinhalbtausend haben wir uns vertan, es sind nur dreieinhalbtausend. Es gab dann so eine Salamitaktik, am Anfang haben sie ein bisschen was rausgegeben, dann noch, war es dann noch ein bisschen. Aber das Verfahren ist jetzt auch zu Ende. Frau Merkel legt Wert darauf, dass immer noch hundert Blatt von diesen dreieinhalbtausend oder viereinhalbtausend Blatt geheim sind. Und dagegen gibt es jetzt auch nichts mehr zu machen. Also selbst zu Eichmann gibt es in der Bundesrepublik noch hundert Blatt Papier, die geheim sind. Und das Bundesverwaltungsgericht hat dem auch zugestimmt.
Also was ich halt...
Aus Gründen der staatsversorgung.
Das Bundeskanzleramt hat argumentiert, es ist so eine angespannte Sicherheitslage. Wir hängen vom den Diensten im Nahen Osten, sprich Mossad, hängen wir ab. Wir möchten nicht, dass die sich ärgern. Und deshalb...
Nein, das haben die nicht erwähnt.
Ja, das haben die, ich glaube, so geschrieben. Die haben den Mossad nicht erwähnt, aber die haben gesagt, wir sind auf die angewiesen, dass wir Informationen bekommen. Und deshalb müssen wir uns daran halten, dass die da Sensibilitäten haben. Das heißt, was wir erfahren, was die deutsche Öffentlichkeit, was die Weltöffentlichkeit über einen Nazi-Massenmörder erfährt, das macht Frau Merkel davon abhängig, was sich eine ausländische Plattform, plattfußorganisation so wünscht.
Und die Frage, die sich ja dann natürlich stellt, ist, wenn du diese Akten so nach und nach bekommst, also jetzt gerade zu Eichmann und die BND-Akten, dann fasert sich ja so eine Investigation irgendwie endlos auf, vermutlich mal. Also wenn du dann das dann endlos viel strenger. Und wie bist du jetzt denn dazu gekommen, diese ganze Geschichte, die wir zu lang sagen, haben wir ja mal erzählen müssen aus deinem Buch, dass dieser Strang jetzt gerade der Interessante, dieser Zusammenhangsstrang ist, den du erzählen wolltest.
Ja, du stößt eine Tür auf und hast zehn weitere verschlossene Türen vor dir, das ist so. Naja, ich bin dann relativ bald schon darauf gestoßen, dass es ein großes militärisches Projekt geben muss zwischen Argentinien und der Bundesrepublik. Das war für die Bundesrepublik vor allem interessant, weil die Bundesrepublik hat ja, das war Bedingung für die Aufnahme in die NATO 1955 bzw. 1957, auf die Entwicklung und der Forschung von ABC, also atomaren, biologischen und chemischen Waffen verzichtet. Das steht aber in dem Text nur drin auf deutschem Boden. Und es hat sich natürlich niemand gehindert, an den Argentinien diese Sachen weiter zu forschen, im Wesentlichen auch, was die atomaren Geschichten angeht. Also die Argentinische Atomkommission ist von deutschen Spezialisten aufgebaut worden. Das war auch das Interesse der Peronisten und auch aber von Argentinien, weil die sagten, naja gut, da fällt für uns was ab. Wir holen die Leute hierher und wir lernen dann auch was. Das ist gemacht worden, so bis 55, und dann sind die auch wieder in die Bundesrepublik im Wesentlichen zurückgegangen, weil auch die Amerikaner dann zu verstehen gegeben haben, sie haben auch nichts gegen die atomare Aufrüstung der Bundesrepublik, man hat dann atomare Sprengkörper auch in der Bundesrepublik ja dann stationiert. Auf jeden Fall, wie war jetzt die Frage?
Na die Frage war, wie hast du gefunden, also wie hast du sozusagen den Strang gefunden, der am Ende in deinem Buch mündet, eben diesem Zusammenhang, also diese Eichmann-Geschichte zu den militärischen atomaren Zusammenarbeitsgeschichten, die da dann passierten?
Ja, einfach auch wegen diesem Grad der Geheimhaltung, den die da machen und zwar bis heute machen. Und dass es um ein atomares Projekt geht, das war mir von vornherein klar. Argentinien hat ja lange Zeit den Atomwaffensperrvertrag nicht unterzeichnet, inzwischen ja. Und sie haben immer die Option gehabt, auch eigene Atomwaffen zu waffen, nicht nur zivile Benutzung der Kernenergie, sondern auch Waffen zu entwickeln, weil sie auch gesagt haben, warum soll das ein Monopol der reichen Industriestaaten sein? Wir wollen das auch haben. Inzwischen, wie gesagt, hat sich das Thema erledigt, aber wir reden jetzt von Ende der 50er, Anfang der 60er Jahre. Und da war eben die engste Zusammenarbeit mit der Bundesrepublik Deutschland von strategischer Bedeutung. Und dazu kam eben irgendwann mal, kamen die Israelis. Wo haben denn die Israelis für die Mona, für ihr Atomkraftwerk, ihr Uran her? Die haben es in Südafrika versucht. Die standen, die konnten das nicht machen, weil die Briten auch dagegen waren. Die Amerikaner waren, die Nordamerikaner, also die USA, war in den 50er Jahren auch noch gegen eine israelische Atombombe. Die wollten ihr Monopol natürlich behalten.
Frankreich hat ihnen doch noch geholfen.
Auch nicht freiwillig, sondern nach der Nasser-Geschichte, nach dem Suisse.
Für die Franzosen haben sie dann Ägypten, die israelische Luftangriffe auf Ägypten, 1956 geflogen. Aber dann gab es in Frankreich 1958 einen Regierungswechsel. Da kam De Gaulle. Und De Gaulle war das sowieso alles unheimlich. Und die Amis haben ihn unter Druck gesetzt. Der wollte auch seine eigene Forst der Frab aufbauen. Und da hat De Gaulle ihnen gesagt, ne passt mal auf, das geht mit mir nicht mehr. Ihr könnt euch aber bei den Deutschen umgucken. Fakt ist, es gibt drei Uran-Lieferungen der Argentinier an Israel. Das ist alles per Dekret entschieden worden. Die Dekrete hab ich, die waren noch nicht mal geheim. Die kann man da aus so einem Orden rausholen. 1960 das erste, da ging es nur um 6 Tonnen. 1962 nochmal 10 Tonnen. Und dann nochmal 63, 100 Tonnen. Also eine riesige Menge eines Materials, was meldepflichtig ist. Und die Amerikaner wussten das. Ich hab die Dokumente, der Department of Energy hat mir diese Sachen frei gegeben, schon vor zwei, drei Jahren. Die wussten von diesen Lieferungen der Argentinier an Israel, eine Lieferung ging über Deutschland, über die Nu-Cam. Da hintersteckt Degussa, das war damals auch eine 100%ige Firma von, die Tochtergesellschaft von Degussa. Und Degussa war zufällig die Firma, die das Patent von Zyklon B innehatte. Wir waren im zweiten Weltkrieg mit dem Giftgas, mit dem die Juden vergast worden sind in den Konzentrationsklangern. Also das ist alles aktenkundig, das kann man haben. Die Sachen sind noch nicht mal geheim. Shimon Peres war in 1959 in Argentinien, hat eben auch mit den Argentiniern im Rahmen einer Schwerwasserprojekte zusammengearbeitet, die Akten sind auch bekannt. Das ist alles schon lange, da habe ich die Sachen rausgefunden. Es gab dann schon ab 1959 eine Wissenschaftlerkommission der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft unter Anführung von Otto Hahn. Die ist nach Israel gefahren, haben da engstens zusammengearbeitet. Die haben zur gleichen Zeit diesen göttigen Appell auch unterschrieben, dass sie gegen Atombewaffnung der Bundesrepublik sind, aber das war dann wohl in ihren Augen eine Art der...
Wiedergutmachung, gell?
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es so was, dass sie sich gesagt haben, die Israelis brauchen das, um ihren Staat zu sichern. Und ja, das ist passiert. Das ist auch alles nicht geheim. Also es musste ein atomares Projekt dahinter sein.
Und wie kamen dann jetzt die Nazis in Argentinien da ins Spiel?
Von denen kam die Atomtechnologie, die die Argentinier benutzt haben. Also das ist auch spannend, wenn du sagst, schweres Wasser, weil das ist so eine deutsche Spezialität. Die amerikanischen Verfahren funktionieren nicht mit schwerem Wasser, sondern die reichern halt ihr Uran an. Aber wenn man schweres Wasser als Moderator nutzt, kann man auch Naturoran nehmen.
Genau, historisch gesehen gibt es immer zwei Linien. Entweder man arbeitet mit schwer angereichertem Uran. Das haben die Amerikaner im Wesentlichen gemacht. Oder Naturoran mit mit Schwerwasser. Grafit kannst du auch als Moderator nehmen. Und dann kommst du zu Plutonium. Und Plutonium hat ja nur einen einen Sinn. Also das macht nur Sinn für für nukleare, für militärische Zwecke, auch zivile nicht. Und das war die deutsche Spezialität. Und das haben eben auch die Israelis dann angewandt. Und die Argentinier haben auch auf der Uranschiene, auf der Naturoranschiene geforscht, weil davon waren sie dann unabhängig von den Kontrollen der US-Amerikaner. Die haben zwar Uran geliefert, angereichertes, aber sie wollten wissen, was damit passiert.
Das war dann diese Atoms for Peace Geschichte.
Das war ja ab 1953 hat es dann Eisenhower in der UNO bekannt gegeben. Im Grunde war das ein ziemliches Ablenkungsmanöver. 1953 kamen schon langsam zwei Sachen heraus. Erstens die Folgen, was Nagasaki und Hiroshima, was die Amerikaner da wirklich angerichtet haben. Die unglaubliche Zerstörung, die hatten ja eine regelrechte Informationssperre. Über fast zehn Jahre lang die Amerikaner, weil das natürlich so furchtbar war. Und da hätten sie mit ihren ganzen atomaren Nöklarenplänen gar nicht mehr weiter machen können, wenn das rausgekommen wäre. Und das zweite war, dass in den 50er Jahren gab es ja dann die Atomwaffenversuche. Im Wesentlichen auch im Pazifik oder ganz oben in der Stratosphäre.
Aber auch in den Wüsten.
In den Wüsten, das kamen ja...
Die europäischen Tests waren ja doch recht viele.
Das Problem ist halt, dass du die sehen kannst.
Du hast den Fallout, du hast diesen radioaktiven Fallout.
Na und du hast einen Atompilz, den man von Seite Ip aus sehen kann.
Ja genau. Und dann gab es eine... Welte öffentlich klingt jetzt sehr viel, aber es gab schon kritische Wissenschaftler und Ärzte, die gesagt haben, das kann so nicht weitergehen. Ganze Regionen verseuchen mit diesem Strontium. Wir müssen zu einem Atom-Stop-Abkommen kommen. Ein Test-Stop-Abkommen. Zwischen der Sowjetunion, Großbritannien und der USA. Das waren die drei Atommächte zu der Zeit. Ich rede jetzt von 1958.
Und die Russen waren ja auch dafür, nicht?
Die Russen waren... Damals gab es Khrushchev und Khrushchev war da unglaublich dahinter. Das geht sowohl aus den Akten des Auswärtigen Amtes, als auch aus den Akten der USA eindeutig hervor. Es gab aber in den USA gab es eine Lobby von Hardlinern. Die saßen in Pentagon und sie saßen in der AEC, in der Atomic Energy Commission, angeführt von John McCown, dem späteren CA-Chef.
Und diese Situation muss man sich mal noch so ein bisschen plastischer vorstellen. Also die so eine Zeit, in der oberen Atomtests stattfinden und in der halt auch der kalte Krieg also wirklich angespannt ist und die Russen und die sowjetz und die Amerikaner doch jeden ihrer Schritte höchst argwürdig beobachten und halt nicht also dem anderen auch überhaupt keinerlei Vertrauensvorschuss geben, sondern irgendwie alles immer sofort auf abklopfen, ob sich irgendwie für Propagandazwecke eigentlich eignet und ob sie halt damit die andere Seite in schlechtem Licht dastehen lassen können. Und war so der Alltag, wenn man so Zeitungen von damals liest, zum Beispiel Alte Spiegel oder so, die gibt's jetzt zum Glück online, die können wir mal lesen. Deshalb kann man sich kaum noch vorstellen, wie sehr jegliche Handlung darauf ausgeleuchtet wurde, ob man jetzt den anderen in den Augen der Weltöffentlichkeit schlecht dastehen lassen kann. Und weil es ihm darum auch zum Beispiel ging, wer kann jetzt seine Machtführer weiter ausweiten? Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen noch der Hintergrund zu dem, was dann danach passiert. Also die spannende Frage ist jetzt so, wie ist jetzt sozusagen die Verbindung zwischen Eichmann und diesen Atom-Testgeschichten?
Na ja, aber es gibt noch eine Sache, nämlich dass die angefangen haben zu der Zeit gerade mit den unterirdischen Atom-Tests, die damals noch nicht von der Gegenseite ortbar waren, weil es noch nicht so ein dichtes, seismisches Netz gab. Also du konntest zwar vermuten, aber du konntest es nicht beweisen. Und diese Atoms for Peace Sache, da war so die Anwendung so was wie, wir bomben uns, ein Ölzugang frei oder wir lenken einen Fluss um. Das wäre auch teilweise unterirdisch gewesen oder nicht?
Nee, nee, nee. Atoms for Peace war 1953. Da hatten die ehrlich gesagt, das war eine Ablenkungsmanöver. Sie wussten noch gar nicht, was sie eigentlich mit dieser zivilen Anwendung überhaupt machen sollten. Also dass man Atomkraft auch für die Energiegewinnung einsetzen kann. Das kam erst ganz, ganz viel später.
Ich ziel ja auch später.
Ja, oder wo man muss jetzt... Die Russennamen ist doch damals verbreitet.
Du redest jetzt von der Operation Plowsharn. Und die kamen 1957, also so Mitte der zweiten Hälfte der 50er Jahre. Da ging es schon darum, eine Antwort zu finden auf den drohenden Atomstopp. Auf ein Abkommen, was drohte. Sie haben gesehen, sie kriegen das nicht vom Tisch. Sie werden das irgendwann, haben sie dann auch machen müssen, im Oktober 58 hat die USA mit der Sowjetunion ein Abkommen über das Verbot von Atomtests abgeschlossen. Und zwar sowohl für die Stratosphäre als auch diese unterirdischen. Aber es ging nur fürs eigene Staatsgebiet. Da steht er eben drin und es gab auch keine Sanktionen. Und es gab eben, du hast das schon erwähnt, keine Kontrollen praktisch. Weil, was ist, wenn du irgendwo unten in irgendeinem Stollen deine Atombombe zündest? Du hast dann zwar bestimmte sessmische Bewegungen, aber erstens, wenn du die irgendwo in Alaska machst, ja wie sollen die damals, 1958 ist die Rede, wie sollen die Russen, die damals festgestellt haben? Und zweitens, ja, du hättest, um wirklich so was ausschließen zu müssen, ein Kontrollnetz, was es heute gibt, also schon länger gibt, damals gab es das doch noch gar nicht. Es gab vielleicht mal irgendwo so eine Universität, so eine Kontrolle, aber die haben also gedacht, wir schließen das Abkommen und gehen trotzdem unseren Weg. Das ist jetzt der Knackpunkt, dass es diese Hardliner im Kabinett von Eisenhower gegeben hat, die gesagt haben, wir sind führend bei der Atomtechnologie. Wenn wir das Abkommen jetzt machen, wenn wir auf die Tests verzichten, verlieren wir unseren Vorsprung gegenüber der Sowjetunion. Und wir haben gerade eine sehr schöne neue Technologie. Wir wollen das auch für zivile Zwecke anwenden. Das will ja die Sowjetunion auch. Die haben da auch eifrig mit rumgebastelt. Wir wollen jetzt das in der zivilen Ingenieurstechnik einsetzen. Haben sie also erfunden und haben gesagt, wir können damit Kanäle bauen, wir können damit Hafenbecken ausbomben. Und es gab dann sogar ein ganz konkretes Projekt, was sie hatten. Sie hatten nämlich eine private Firma, das war die Panama Canal Company. Die wollte einen zweiten Kanal bauen in Mittelamerika, weil es gab interne Schwierigkeiten in Panama. Die haben gefürchtet, dass sie die Kanalzone verlieren. Und dann haben sie diverse Routen ausgetestet, einen durch Mexiko, einen durch Nicaragua, einen durch Kolumbien, alles ausgerechnet und sind dann dazu gekommen, wenn sie gesagt haben, wenn wir das mit konventionellen Sprengstoffen machen, dann brauchen wir erstens zehn Jahre und zweitens brauchen wir zwei Milliarden Dollar. Weil da muss man also ein Loch bohren, da muss man den Sprengstoff rein, das Dynamit da unten hin, dann macht's Puff und dann hat man das Loch und hat man den ganzen Schutt und dann muss man den Schutt wegräuben. Wenn wir aber das Loch bohren und dann tun wir da so eine Atombombe rein, dann macht's auch aber ein richtig kräftiges Puff, aber dann haben wir den Krater. Das ist ja der Unterschied. Und der Krater ist ja schon nackt, das heißt wir brauchen da keine Schutt wegräuben. Dann sparen wir uns also eine Menge Geld. Diese ganzen Details, diese Rechnungen...
Das ist ein bisschen Fallout.
Das hab ich alles. Die liegen in Kansas in der Library. Die waren auch nicht mal geheim. Die haben das also ausgerechnet, das ist ein Zehntel nur der Kosten. Die Panama-Kanal-Gesellschaft ist auch dafür. Und die Atombomben kommen sowieso vom Pentagon. Und das geht alles viel schneller. Und das wollen wir jetzt machen.
Und wo sollte der langgehende Kanal?
Sie hatten vier Routen, wie gesagt, aber alle durch Mittelamerika. Die wahrscheinlichste wäre wahrscheinlich Nicaragua gewesen. Und das haben die auch öffentlich diskutiert. Das ist jetzt nicht, dass das irgendwie in der Zeitung gestanden ist. Man hat auch dann diesen Kanal, Pernitormic-Kanal genannt. Und diese Sachen, die sind damals schon declassified, also offengelegt gewesen. Der Chef von der Company, der hat das richtig ausgerechnet und hat gesagt, ja, wir machen das wie so eine Art Perlenkette, so Krater an Krater. Und dann zum Schluss haben wir ja schon dann den Kanal. Das geht ganz flott und ist so billig und ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Und der Fallout verdünnt sich dann durchs Wasser oder Säue?
Ja, es gibt auch nichts. Wir haben auch keine Probleme mit dem Grundwasser. Es gibt überhaupt, man kann natürlich auch geologisch ein bisschen untersuchen, sie hatten ein großes Problem. Sie mussten das hier irgendwo testen. Und dann kam im Oktober 1958 das Abkommen mit der Silvett Union, dass sie auf Tests verzichten, auch unterirdische. So, und dann hatten sie ein Problem.
Okay, und wie ging es dann weiter?
Also ich wollte dann die Unterlagen sehen in den USA. Das heißt, ich wollte dann in den USA, ich recherchiere ja zweimal, was weiß ich, alle zwei Jahre fahre ich in die USA und gehe da in die Archive. Wobei das eigentlich, also man kann die USA, in den USA die Archive nicht mit unseren deutschen Archiven vergleichen. Es gibt schon eine ganz andere Tradition, was mit dem Umgang von, auch von geheimen Dokumenten ist. Da ist die Bundesrepublik ein Obrigkeitstaat. In den USA macht es wirklich Spaß, im Bundesarchiv zu recherchieren. Ich habe da immer recherchiert, ich kenne da die ganzen Archivware, die sind klasse. Und das ist wirklich wunderbar. Ja, dann wollte ich, wann war das? Im August 2010. Da bin ich also mit dem gültigen Visum dahin und habe auch gesagt, ich gehe zu Nara. Und bin dann an der Grenze hinter der Passkontrolle, hinter der Gepärkontrolle rausgefischt worden und nach sieben Stunden Verhör wieder ins nächste Flugzeug gesetzt worden. Ohne Begründung. Ich habe bis heute keine Begründung dafür bekommen. Mir haben dann andere Forscher geholfen. Die sind dann für mich nach Kansas gefahren, weil die haben für jeden Präsidenten eine eigene Library, also eine eigene Bibliothek, die aber auch NARA, also dem Bundesarchiv, untersteht. Also da gilt das Bundesgesetz in den USA. Aber das macht es natürlich für private Forscher, macht das wirklich sehr schwierig. Also Kansas ist 3000 Kilometer von Washington entfernt. Also da sind meine Freunde, die sind da hingefahren. Bei einer zwei Tage unterwegs oder drei überhaupt da hinzukommen, das ist alles teuer natürlich. Das machen sie absichtlich, um uns das zu erschweren. Ja, und dann haben die mir alles zugemailt per E-Mail. Und aus diesen Akten entnehme ich, also erstens diese Versessenheit von John McCone und Eisenhower, so Pentagon, diesen Ditchtaker, haben sie das genannt, diesen atomaren Grabenbagger von Edward Teller und Herbert York, auszuprobieren. Edward Teller ist, ich weiß nicht, erinnert ihr euch?
Der Vater der Atombombe, sagt man.
Der Wasserstoffbombe.
Ja, was auch nicht so ganz stimmt. Aber es gibt diesen wahnsinnig schönen Film, Dr. Seltsam und wie ich lernte, die Bombe zu lieben. Das ist so ein bisschen die Parodie auf ihn. Völlig durchgeknallten, antikommunistischen Physiker, wenn man die Akten wirklich liest. Genial war er nicht. Er hat den Mafid mit Meters verwechselt und konnte auch nicht richtig rechnen. Aber zumindest hat das alles in damals in das allgemeine Umfeld, in das politische reingepasst. Und Herbert Yorke war auch schon bei dem Manhattan-Projekt, bei dem Atomwaffen-Projekt der USA, wir waren des Zweiten Weltkriegs dabei. Und er war in der Zeit der Oberatomwaffenentwickler des Pentagons. Und die haben eben sehr darauf gedrängt, endlich diese Waffe zu testen. Und es gibt dann zwei Kabinettssitzungen, eine am 5. Mai 1960, die andere am 12. Mai 1960. Da war auch Herbert Yorke und Teller waren dann auch geladen, kamen auch und haben vorgetragen. Und dann fehlen ganz viele Blätter. Da gibt es diese berühmten Entnahmeblätter. Und auf einem steht ja nur noch, Präsident Eisenhower befiehlt jetzt, alles was hier beredet wird, alles zu vernichten. Und dann kommt da nichts mehr.
Immerhin gibt es die Entnahmeblätter. Es gibt ja auch Fälle, wo da nicht mal ein Entnahmeblatt liegt. Aber es fehlt offensichtlich was.
Ja, die habe ich ja auch aufgrund der Entnahmeblätter, habe ich jetzt auch die Freigabe beantragt. Ein paar habe ich bekommen. Die CIA zum Beispiel hat sie alle abgelehnt, weil sie sagen, sie ist nicht US-Staatsbürgerin. Stimmt ja auch. Stimmt ja. Ja gut, jetzt ein Freund von mir, der ist US-Staatsbürger. Der hat jetzt auch beantragt. Das heißt, das geht jetzt seinen juristischen Weg.
Okay, und worum ging es bei dieser Kabinettsetzung?
Es ging um das Testen dieses Grabenbuggers. Sie wollten diesen Plan, die wollten unterirdische Zündungen durchführen.
Im Kern ging es ja darum, dass sie die Wasserstoffbombe noch nicht so lange hatten zu der Zeit.
Es ging doch gar nicht um die Wasserstoffbombe. Es gingen ganz normale, relativ kleine Atombomben.
Also die taktische Atombombe.
Ja genau, und zwar relativ kleine. Also wie gesagt, es ging um so eine atomare Perlenkette. Und dieser Grabenbagger, der hätte sich also so Atombombe hier, Atombombe da, so durch das Erdreich gebaggert. Ja, wie so eine Fräsmaschine kann man sagen. Und das wollte Herr Teller natürlich oder Herr jorg wollten das ausprobieren. Und ab dem Moment, ab dem 12. Mai ist nichts mehr in den Akten drin. Weder bei Pentagon noch Atomkommission, noch Kabinett, noch National Security Council. Nichts mehr. Ich bin dann, das Witzige war, als ich den Namen Herbert jorg gelesen habe, ich habe immer gedacht, Mensch, scheiße, den kennst du. Irgendwie ist dir der Name schon mal über den Weg gelaufen. Und hab dann in der kleinen Computer gemerkt, Herbert jorg ist am 15. Mai 1960 in Banas Aires gelandet, mit vier YouTube-Aufklärungsspionage, Flugzeugen der Air Force und drei riesigen Atomwaffenträgern und einer Superfortress, auch mit Atomwaffen an Bord. Und ist damit nach Argentinien gekommen. Ich habe daraufhin versucht herauszufinden, auf welchen Flughäfen die waren, was sie gemacht haben. Die Argentinische Regierung, ich habe mit denen gesprochen, mehrere Male, mit dem Verteidigungsminister, sie haben irgendwann total abgeblockt und haben einfach nur noch wissen wollen, was ich weiß. Und haben mir dann den sämtlichen Zugang zu den Flughäfen blockiert und zur Migrationsbehörde, weil ich natürlich wissen wollte, wer ist da eingereist noch. Und ich bin dann über die Marine, habe ich dann diesen Ditzschdegger, also diesen Grabenbagger verfolgt, nach Südpatagonien, aber wirklich ganz, ganz tief in die, nach Südpatagonien. Und bin dann in einen Hafen gekommen, nach Puerto de Ciudad, ich habe mir das auch angeguckt dann und habe dort festgestellt, wo sie diese Detonation gemacht haben damals.
Also die haben die tatsächlich dann in Argentinien getestet?
Ich habe mit einem Arbeiter gesprochen, in Chile, den haben sie vorher, schon Monate vorher unter Vertrag genommen. Der hat mit normalem Sprengstoff, weil zu den eigentlichen Sprengungen ist er dann nicht mehr dazu gezogen worden. Da kamen dann Experten aus dem Ausland. Der hat da die Löcher gebohrt, um dort Sprengstoff zu detonieren. Weißt du, das klingt jetzt ganz komisch, was ich sage, aber dieses ganze Ding macht irgendwie Sinn, wenn man das aus der Perspektive der jeweils Betroffenen anguckt. Ich sag das jetzt mal, die Perspektive der Argentinier. Die Argentinier wollten mit dabei sein. Da gibt es eine vielversprechende neue Technologie, da wollten sie dabei sein. So haben sie die Amis eingeladen, dann sagt, mach das doch bei uns. Wir haben die Oberhoheit hier, ihr kommt zu uns, zur Marine, und dann gehen wir unten nach Patagonien, da lebt fast niemand. So, dann machen wir das. Puerto de Ciado ist ein Dorf, damals wohnten da 4.000 Leute. Das liegt am Rio de Ciado, auf Deutsch der ersehnte Fluss. Wie der Name schon sagt, der Fluss ist sehr ersehend. Der kam mal vor der letzten Eiszeit, kam er aus den Anden, vom Lago, vom See Bonas Aires, am Gletschersee, in den Anden. Und dann kam die Eiszeit, dann haben die Vulkane gespuckt und dann ist der letzte Teil von diesem Fluss, der in die Bucht bei Puerto de Ciado in den Atlantik mündet, ist verschüttet worden und der läuft seitdem unterirdisch. Also man weiß, wenn man in der Bucht ist, hier kommt Süßwasser rein. Das kann man ja feststellen, aber wir wissen nicht, wo das kommt. Und die Stadt Puerto de Ciado hat bis heute nicht genug Süßwasser. Also die haben rationiert. Nun, würdet ihr sagen, das ist doch klasse, da bauen wir eine Leitung. Entweder von Anden, das wären 900 Kilometer, oder von der Stelle, wo der Fluss versiegt. Haben die argentinischen Militärs aber gesagt, nee, das machen wir jetzt mit Ordnung und wir wollen jetzt wieder die Ordnung herstellen von dem Flusslauf, wie er vor der Eiszeit war. Und wir bauen jetzt den Kanal. Die wollten also einen Kanal bauen von der Bucht bis zu der Stelle, wo er versiegt. Ja, wäre nicht so weit gewesen. Ja, und dazu hätten sie natürlich die Hilfe von den Amerikanern gebraucht. Und sie haben dabei, die Amerikaner haben gesagt, die kannten ja auch die Gegend nicht, das ist eine vulkanische Gegend. Der Fluss ist verbunden mit den Anden, mit den Gletscherseen, mit den Vulkanen der Anden. Du musst natürlich vor jeder Sprengung musst du auch die geologische Struktur untersuchen. Haben sie natürlich nicht gemacht. Haben da einfach ein bisschen rumgebombt. Und naja gut, wenn sie dann...
Na die Theorie der elektronischen Platten gab es auch noch gar nicht so.
Die gab es noch gar nicht, die fingen ja erst danach an. Und sie wussten, wenn sie ein bisschen da rumbomben, dann muss es natürlich sysmische Bewegungen geben. Aber in ganz Südpatagonien, also in ganz Argentinien, weiß ich nicht, ob es überhaupt eine Kontrollstation gab. Also da unten gab es jedenfalls keine. Das weiß ich sicher. So haben sie gesagt, selbst wenn es da ein bisschen wackelt oder rumpst, das kriegen wir ja, da wohnen ja nur ein paar Fischer oder so, das rumpst, das ist ein bisschen, das fällt ja gar nicht auf. So, wie gesagt, es ist eine vulkanische Gegend. Und wenn man auf die Anden geht, die Anden sind auf der einen Seite, das ist Argentinien, auf der anderen Seite ist es Chile. Und in Chile, an der Pazifiküste, prallen zwei tektonische Platten, nämlich die Nazca-Platte auf die südamerikanische Platte aufeinander. Und sie haben diesen Ditzschdigger, ich hab den ja verfolgt, in dem Militärschiff nach Puerto Desiado, der kam da am 18. im Hafen an, am 19. ist er an den Ort der Detonationen gebracht worden, ich geh mal davon aus, am 20. oder 21. war er einsatzbereit. Wie wir heute wissen, das weiß man, kann man ins Guinness Buch der Weltrekorde gehen, da muss man nicht sich irgendwelche sessmischen Statistiken reinziehen. Am 21. Mai hat das Erdbeben von Valdivia angefangen in Chile und am 22. war es auf dem Höhepunkt mit einer Stärke von 9,5 Grad auf der Richterskala. Das ist das Größte, was jemals in der Welt gemessen worden ist überhaupt. Wo ganze Berge sich verschoben haben, neue Seen entstanden, es gab sogar Tsunamis. Der Tsunami ging bis zu den Philippinen, bis nach Hawaii und die ganze kalifornische Küste ist auch zerstört worden. Es gab zwei Millionen Obdachlose und nur deshalb knapp 2.000 Tote, weil Südchile so ganz dünn besiedelt ist. Es war eine wahnsinnige Katastrophe und natürlich haben die sich damals in der Situation gedacht, das waren wir. Was wir heute wissen über die Entstehung von solchen Erdbeben, habe mit den Geologen und Physikern gesprochen, ist was ganz anderes. Solche Erdbeben entstehen über Jahrzehnte, die hitzen sich sozusagen, die Spannung bot sich auf. Durch diese Subduktion, wenn sich eine Platte unter die andere schiebt, wird unglaublich viel Energie gespeichert, gespeichert, nochmal gespeichert und irgendwann mal geht das dann mit einem riesigen Rumpf raus. Du kannst aber so ein Erdbeben auslösen, nicht verursachen.
Wenn es gespeichert sozusagen, die Energie schon da ist.
Den letzten Funken dann noch geben.
Und die dachten, sie waren es.
Sie haben sogar gedacht, sie haben das verursacht und dass sie dann in Zukunft in der Lage sein werden, tectonische Waffen auch zu entwickeln. Also Herr Teller war ein Verrückter. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen, wenn man sich die Sachen von dem Typen durchliest heute, dann denkt man nur, der hat Dachschaden gehabt. Aber damals haben die mit Sicherheit dann wie wild angefangen zu forschen. Es hat fast 20 Jahre gedauert, bis die UNO eine internationale Konvention zusammenkriegt, um solche wetterbeeinflussenden Waffen und Maßnahmen zu bannen. Aber so lange, also bis Ende der 70er Jahre, hat es diese Forschung, vermute in der ganzen Welt, ich glaube nicht, dass die Russen bei was anderes gemacht haben, die hat es gegeben.
Okay, also die Situation ist, Teller ist da unten?
Nee, ob Teller da ist, weiß ich nicht. Herbert jorg war da.
jorg war da mit Atomwaffen.
Und Sie dachten, Sie haben gerade den halben Kontinent gesprengt und brauchen jetzt eine Anblenkung.
Und was passierte dann?
Ja, das war am 22., wo das große Erdbeben war. Das ist jetzt die Frage, was dann passierte. Die Sachen sind ja noch geheim, aber es ist doch sehr auffällig, dass am 23. Mai in Israel um 4 Uhr Ortszeit Israel, das ist morgens um 9 in Washington DC, das Bengorion völlig überraschend, und zwar auch zur Überraschung seiner allerängsten Mitarbeiter, vor die Knässe tritt und sagt, wir haben Eichmann und wir stellen ihn hier vor Gericht wegen Verbrechen gegen das jüdische Volk. Er hat noch nicht mal seinen engen Kumpel Konrad Adenauer, mit dem er seit März 1960 über die Zahlung von zwei Milliarden D-Map für das israelische Atomprogramm verhandelt hat. Und man war sich ja schon geschäftseinig geworden. Er hat es noch nicht mal geschafft, zum Hörer zu greifen und ihm zu sagen, Konrad, alter Knacker, frag mich nicht wieso.
Wir haben da ein Problem.
Wir haben da ein Problem. Irgendwann erkläre ich es dir. Ich muss das, wir müssen jetzt umdisponieren. Macht ihr keine sorgen, wir werden eure Interessen irgendwie versuchen zu verteidigen. Ich muss das jetzt machen. Er hätte doch zwei Stunden warten können und den Beauftragten der Israel-Mission aus Köln nach Röndorf schicken können, um Konrad zu beruhigen. Das hat er nicht getan. Adenauer ist total davon überrascht worden. Er hat keine Ahnung von nichts gehabt und der ist explodiert. Und wenn das er auf dem BND geschimpft hat, das ist noch eine andere Sache. Der BND wusste natürlich von gar nichts.
Okay, aber was war Adenaures Motivation, sich darüber zu eschöphieren, dass die Israelis Eichmann haben?
Na, wir müssen den rechtlichen Hintergrund erst mal erklären.
Adenauer, wir müssen uns die auch vorstellen, das Jahr 1960, Adenauer wollte ja wieder Weltpolitik irgendwie mitmischen und er musste irgendwie das ganze Problem mit der Judenvernichtung irgendwie vom Tisch kriegen. Es ist schon Anfang der 50er Jahre, ist diese sogenannte Wiedergutmachung gezahlt worden. Das hat Herr Abs damals eingetütet, nicht ganz offiziell als Vertreter. Das war aber explizit nicht an militärische Dinge geknüpft. Dann hat sich im März 1960 Ben Goyon mit Adenauer in New York am Rande einer UNO-Vollversammlung im Hotel Astoria getroffen. Dann haben die beiden alten Männer geredet. Das Auswärtige Amt hat mir gegenüber die Akten freigegeben. Wir wissen inzwischen, was da alles verabredet worden ist, nämlich die Operation Geschäftsfreund. Da ist vorbei, am deutschen Parlament, sogar am deutschen Finanzminister, zumindest in der Anfangszeit, haben die da einen richtigen Art Mafia-Pakt geschlossen. Ganz geheim. Und zwei Milliarden D-Mark, zwar unglaublich viel Geld damals, für ein Entwicklungsprojekt in der israelischen Negerwüste gezahlt.
Also D-Mona.
D-Mona, ja. Und in einem anderen Dokument heißt es auch, man hat über die Produktion atomarer Waffen gesprochen und und und.
Also kurze Erklärung, D-Mona ist die israelische Atomforschungseinrichtung, in der auch die israelischen Atomwaffen produziert werden und die entsprechenden Anreichungssysteme stehen.
Genau. So, die waren sich also alle im Prinzip einig. Die Bundesrepublik hat schon im März mit einem 3-Millionen-Kredit aus dem Etat des Atomministeriums spendiert. Damit also auch Hahn und die Leute nach Israel fahren konnten. Damit es den Transfer von Technologie gab. Man war sich in allem einig. Man hatte alles schon unter Dach und Fach. Man war sich über gewisse Auszahlungsmodalitäten noch nicht klar.
Der Atomminister war Franz Josef Strauß übrigens. Das fand ich ja auch sehr lustig.
Der erste Atomminister war Franz Josef Strauß. Er war zu dem Zeitpunkt, hatte er irgendwie so eine Lusche dann dagelassen. Er war Verteidigungsminister schon zu dem Zeitpunkt. Aber er hat immer noch die Sachen gemanagt im Atomministerium.
Was man vielleicht ein bisschen verstehen muss zur Beurteilung der Lage, ist, dass völkerrechtlich gab es schon eine Lösung dafür, dass nicht irgendwelche Länder jetzt anfangen, Alten Nazis zu verfolgen und Deutschland schlecht aussehen zu lassen. Denn völkerrechtlich war Deutschland und nur Deutschland verantwortlich für das Verfolgen von Alten Nazis. Und das heißt, die größte Bedrohung war für jemanden wie Adelnauer, dessen halbes Kabinett aus Alten Nazis bestand, dass jetzt jemand wie Israel ist natürlich der absolute Gauer, aber das im Grunde jedes Land wäre peinlich gewesen, wenn die jetzt anfangen, irgendwelche Alten Nazis auszugraben und den Prozess zu machen, weil Deutschland den Hintern nicht hochkriegt. Und Israel hat natürlich an der Stelle, da hätte man auch nicht irgendwie sagen können, das geht jetzt nicht. Insofern, das war quasi das, was unbedingt verhindert werden musste, dass Israel jetzt anfängt, irgendwelche Alten Nazis zu verfolgen. Insofern, so erklärt sich, dass Adenauer bereit war, diese unglaubliche Geldmenge in die Hand zu nehmen. Weil da stand mehr auf dem Spiel als bloß, wir wollen jetzt mitmachen, sondern es ging auch um das Selbsterhaltung von ihm oder nicht.
Ja, aber Israel haben sie doch nicht gefürchtet. Ich meine, da war ja Ben-Goyon an der Regierung. Ben-Goyon und der Zionismus hat in den 30er-Jahren ja eng mit, gerade auch mit Eichmann und mit den Nazis zusammengearbeitet. Das ist ja noch ein ganz anderes Kapitel, über das man ja überhaupt gar nicht reden will. Und Ben-Goyon hat niemals auch nur daran gedacht, irgendwie Nazis in der Welt zu jagen, wo die Gefahr ausging. Das waren so Länder, also im Ersten Linie Griechenland und die haben das ja auch gemacht. Die haben ja dann auch 1957 den Mertins dann, jetzt war ein Mitglied der deutschen Militärverwaltung während der Besetzung, den haben sie dann einfach eingekascht und dann haben sie ihn vor Gericht gestellt und verurteilt. Und das hat Deutschland viel Geld gekostet, um den wieder rauszukriegen. Weil natürlich ging es immer auch um Reparationszahlungen. Das war im Grunde der Hintergrund davon. Sie wollten das irgendwann mal unter Dach und Fach kriegen und nicht mit neuen Ansprüchen konfrontiert werden.
Naja und auch, dass die Leute nicht anfangen auszupacken. Wenn sie dann in Griechenland angeklagt sind, wenn dir dann sagt, ja aber ich bin doch nur eine kleine Leuchte, meine vorgesetzten waren Herr Sozo, Sozo und Sozo.
Oder meine Spitzel. Das hat ja dann auch der Mertins gesagt. Der hat dann auch gesagt, Leute, die dann in der aktuellen Politik waren, der hat doch immer mit den deutschen Behörden auch während der Besatzung zusammengearbeitet. Also solche Peinlichkeiten wollte man alle mal verhindern. Und ich meine, Israel hat niemals irgendwelche Nazis in der Welt gesucht.
Das ist ja genau das Gegenteil dessen, wie man es heute lernt oder kennt. Heute feiern sie sich ja als die Leute, die Gerechtigkeit bringen und die hier die ganzen belasteten Leute. Also zwei, drei gab es ja auch, es war ja nicht nur Eichmann, sondern es gab den einen, hast du schon erwähnt, aber es gab, glaube ich, einige Mossad-Aktionen, die sich selbst gefeiert haben als auch die Sache in der Schweiz, weswegen da jetzt die typomatische Beziehung so ein bisschen belastet sind. Das war ja auch so eine Gerechtigkeitssache. Also diese ganze Idee, dass der Mossad der Gerechtigkeit dient, kommt ja von Eichmann.
Ja, aber das haben sie dann benutzt. Es gibt ja diesen Film von dem Spielberg, Moonage, wo er Golda Meier sagen lässt, so wie wir Gerechtigkeit im Falle Eichmanns geschaffen haben, so machen wir auch Gerechtigkeit bei den Palästinensern. Und dann haben sie ja dieses Kommando der Schwarzer September, die ja Einzelnen abknallen lassen und haben sich darauf moralisch dann auf die Eichmann-Operationen berufen. Aber ich meine, das war eine Legitimation gemacht. Haben sie nie was. Deshalb ist es ja auch so ein empfindliches Thema in Israel. Wenn jetzt rauskommt, und es kommt ja, ich meine, die interessierten Leute wissen es heute ja auch schon, wenn jetzt rauskommt, es war so nicht. Und es waren ganz andere Zusammenhänge und auch militärische Zusammenhänge da, dann wird das schon ziemlich peinlich.
Also die schönste Szene war in dem Buch, wenn ich das kurz zitieren darf, gibt es so ein BND-Memo, was du da zitierst, wo der Botschafter aus Israel berichtet, dass die Begründung quasi war von Ben Gurion, na endlich haben wir was. Der Mossad hat ja nur Scheiße gemacht bisher. Endlich haben wir mal was, worauf wir zeigen können, dass sie auch ein erfolgreicher Geheimdienst sind.
Das CIA war das.
Oder die CIA war das?
Ja, das war das CIA-Ding. Die wollten ohnehin, die hatten so Probleme beim Haushalt, aber den wollten sie irgendwie kurzen. Und dann haben sie sich jetzt endlich mal was vorzuzeigen, das ist jetzt populär.
Und darauf begrüßen sich ja das gesamte Selbstbild vom Mossad in der Presse.
Okay, und wie kommt jetzt Eichmann ins Spiel?
Eichmann hat mit dieser ganzen Geschichte, wir haben eben über diese unterirdischen Atomversuche geredet, überhaupt nichts zu tun. Das ist am selben Ort, zur selben Zeit hat das stattgefunden und das haben sie als Ablenkungsmanöver benutzt. Die Amerikaner und was...
Also deine These ist, dass die Amerikaner schon lange wussten, wo Eichmann ist und ihn quasi aus dem Eisschrank geholt haben, als es opportun war, weil sie eine Ablenkungsgeschichte brauchten.
Das wussten nicht nur die Amerikaner, das wussten alle. Also ich meine, in den BND-Akten steht auch drin, dass der Sassen, der hat den Eichmann ja ab 56 Jahre lang, dann auch mehrere Jahre, interviewt, der hat für die US-Botschaft gearbeitet. Ich habe einen Antrag, da laufen schon seit Ewigkeiten, die Beantworten sagen einfach nichts dazu.
Du hast ja auch beim BND eine Karteikarte gefunden aus dem Jahre 1952, wo schon drauf steht, der Eichmann ist in Argentinien. Also das hat mich auch vom Hocker gehauen.
Das war eigentlich noch die am wenigsten aussagekräftige Geschichte. Also in den 40er Jahren ist Eichmann ja öfters auch nach Altausee, also in die Berge nach Österreich gefahren. Und es war ja gar nicht klar direkt nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg, dass der Krieg zu Ende ist. Es gab ja auch die Tendenz, dass man eventuell nur ein bisschen ausharrt und dann unter US-Oberkommando weiter in den Osten geht. Und da gibt es auch freigegebene Akten vom BND. Also die wussten zu allen Zeiten, wo Eichmann war. Und der BND hatte ganz viele Spitzel auch um Eichmann herum. Der wusste zu jeder Zeit, wo er war. Und ich meine, ein Dokument vom BND ist, dass Eichmann auch für den Mossad oder für die Israelis gearbeitet hat. Und in Argentinien, also die innenpolitische Situation, es gibt unglaublich viele argentinische Flüchtlinge, die in Argentinien leben. Und diese deutschen Kreise, denn das waren ja deutsche Juden, die haben Deutsch gesprochen. Und dann kamen nach 1900 Jahren der Gründung der Bundesrepublik, kamen dann die ganzen Nazis nach Argentinien, die haben auch Deutsch gesprochen.
In dieselbe deutsche Community.
In dieselbe und die gingen zum selben deutschen Bäcker und die haben dieselbe deutsche Leberwurst eingekauft und sind in auch in dieselben Konzerte gegangen. Und man hat sich dann irgendwie auch gesehen da. Und die haben auch im selben Stadtviertel gewohnt oder vielleicht drei Häuser blocks weiter weg. Und die Kinder sind in dieselben Schulen gegangen.
Ich fand ja den Hammer, dass Mengele und Eichmann da unter ihrem richtigen Namen aufgetreten sind.
Die Kinder von Eichmann sind als Eichmann in die deutsche Schule gegangen. Und Mengele hat 1956 einen Pass in der deutschen Botschaft auf seinen Namen bekommen.
Unglaublich.
Und er hat als Glaubenhaftmachung, dass er Mengele ist, hat er nur Entscheidungsurte vorlegen können. Es hat gereicht.
Okay. Und das heißt also, die hatten Mengele quasi, hatten Eichmann quasi auf Vorrat. Der war da halt.
Ja, und der hat ja auch bei Mercedes-Benz gearbeitet. Und da waren ja auch die ganzen alten SSler.
Okay. Und dann, was passierte dann? Also was ist deine These? Wie lief denn dieses Ablenkungsmanöver?
Na ja, der Eichmann muss ja schon irgendwo gewesen sein im Nahen Osten, in Israel.
Der sprach ja sogar Hebräisch, hab ich in deinem Buch gelernt. Bin ich auf was vom Stuhl gefallen, so weil er halt mit den Zionisten zusammen, ja ich war nicht so der Eichmann-Forscher, weil er halt mit den zionistischen Organisationen zusammengearbeitet hat in den dreißiger Jahren.
Den Teil müssen wir glaube ich noch mal ein bisschen erklären, weil das glaube ich für viele Hörer ein bisschen zu krass ist, dass man es mal nicht erläutern kann. Also wir springen jetzt mal kurz zurück in die Zeit. Die Nazis sind an die Macht gekommen und wollen heute ein Judenfreies Deutschland haben. Und was wir im Geschichtsunterricht gelernt haben, sind ja immer nur so die groben Outlines von dem, was passiert. Aber was du ja auch sehr eindringlich und detailliert beschreibst, ist ja auch tatsächlich so die Mechanismen der Enteignung und die Mechanismen, das in die Flucht treiben ist. Und das Bild, was sich da mir so darstellt, ist ja, als hätten die Nazis erst mal quasi alle jüdischen Familien, die irgendwie Geld hatten, ausgenommen, indem sie ihnen eine Fluchtmöglichkeit aufgerührt haben, gegen Geld. Und dann alle, die es sich nicht leisten konnten, halt irgendwie ermordet. Also, um es mal ganz kurz zusammenzufassen, ist das korrekt so als?
Es ist nicht so richtig korrekt. Ab 1933 gab es drei Phasen der Judenverfolgung. Und die erste Phase, das würde ich zu sagen, das war eine Diskriminierung. Also, man hat sie aus bestimmten Berufen rausgeschmissen. Man hat sie diskriminiert, man hat sie fertiggemacht, man hat Kampagnen gemacht, kauft mich beim Juden. So, diese Geschichten. Es gab ja dann auch schon relativ bald die Nürnberger Rassengesetze, eben kommentiert dann von Herrn Globke. Und es gab dann 1933 sehr bald aufgrund dieser Diskriminierung eine weltweite Kampagne, wir müssen gegen das Hitlerregime Beukott machen. Also, wir kaufen jetzt keine deutschen Waren mehr. Und dann hat man sich in Deutschland gedacht, aha, wie machen wir das? Wir machen jetzt ein Abkommen mit den zionistischen Organisationen. Und sie haben dann im August 1933 zusammen mit den zionistischen Organisationen ein Abkommen gemacht, das sogenannte Havara-Abkommen, das deutsche Juden, die nach Palästina, also in das zukünftige Israel, emigrieren wollen, die können hier ihren Besitz verkaufen und geben das auf ein Konto bei der Deutschen Bank. Ganz merkwürdig, weil es herrschte noch die Wiesenkontrolle, aber die haben die Deutsche Bank sich ausgesucht, aus gutem Grund. Und das wird dann nach Palästina überwiesen. Und dann können die Juden, die ausgewanderten Juden, aus Deutschland, Waren importieren und dort verkaufen. Und sozusagen ihren Besitz wieder zu Geld machen. Das heißt, sie haben auf diese Art und Weise praktisch den Boykott unterlaufen. Und es gab dann auf den Tragungen des jüdischen Weltkongresses, gab es irre Auseinandersetzungen von Anfang an, also von 1933 an, weil die Zionisten waren eine ganz hauchdünne, kleine Gruppe. Die hatten keineswegs die Mehrheit. Und die Gründung eines Staates Israel, also die Mehrheit der deutschen Juden, die wollten ihre Rechte verteidigen und nicht irgendwo da in der Wüste zwischen den Sandflöhen da einen Staat gründen. Die haben überhaupt nicht daran gedacht. Also deshalb musste man die ja auch sozusagen dahin prügeln. Und die waren am Anfang gar nicht begeistert. Ja, und dann hat man dieses Abkommen dann durchgesetzt, die Zionisten zusammen mit den Nazis. Und da war eben der Ansprechpartner innerhalb des SD, des Sicherheitsdienstes DSS, eben auch Adolf Eichmann. Und er hat damals auch Hebräisch gelernt, sprach wohl auch Jiddisch, um sich mit diesen Leuten auch verständigen zu können. Und er wurde dann in der zweiten Phase, das hörte dann auf vor allem, als dann der Zweite Weltkrieg, also ab September 1939, ausbrach. Es klappte dann mit der Auswanderung nicht mehr und die britische Mandatsmacht wollte die Leute sowieso nicht, da alle im Nahen Osten haben. Und dann gab es die zweite Phase, dann ist Eichmann nach Wien gegangen, wurde Leiter der Zentralstelle für jüdische Auswanderung. Und da war das schon nicht nur Diskriminierung, sondern man hat die Leute systematisch auch fertig gemacht, dass sie ihren Wohnung geschmissen, physisch angegriffen. Also das war schon ziemlich Terror, wie man dann gegen die jüdische Bevölkerung losgegangen ist. Da sind auch noch mal sehr viele emigriert. Zum Teil konnten sie noch Sachen mitnehmen, zum Teil auch nicht mehr. Und die dritte Phase ist dann so ab Ende 41 und dann eben spätestens mit der Wannsee-Konferenz ab Januar 42, wo dann eben die physische Vernichtung der europäischen Juden beschlossen war. Dass man ihnen systematisch ans Geld ging, das kam auch erst Ende der 30er Jahren mit der sogenannten Judenvermögensabgabe, wo sie praktisch ihre gesamten Besitztümer den Finanzämtern gegenüber darlegen mussten und es wurde alles konfisziert. Also die Aktien, die Bargeld, diese ganzen Geschichten, das hat man alles eingezogen.
Du beschreibst so eine ganz witzige Szene in dem Buch über die Juden, die dann in Palästina ankommen, mit einem deutschen Pass. Und dann kommen die Behörden vor Ort, die von den Briten geschickten Grenzer und sagen, der Pass hier, na guck mal, ob der korrekt ist, rufen in Deutschland an. Und Deutschland hat gesagt, nee, den kennen wir nicht, den Pass. Der ist kein Deutscher, den könnt ihr nicht zurückschicken. Also die Prioritäten an der Stelle fand ich sehr witzig. Hauptdeutsch-Priorität war, die kommen nicht zurück. Und eigentlich wollte die aber auch die keine andere haben. Also nicht nur die Briten ja nicht, aber dieses Gespiele mit dem Pass, finde ich, fand ich sehr beeindruckend, dass man die quasi da, dass die so tricksen mussten, um überhaupt jemanden zu finden, der die Juden aufnehmen wollte.
Wir wollten die ja auch nicht aufnehmen. Die Juden wollten, die hatten eigentlich gar keinen Platz, wo sie hingehen sollten. Weil sich die ganze Welt ihnen auch verschlossen hatte. Aber die Juden, die dann ausgewandert sind nach Palästina, den gingen es auch bis auf jetzt so ein paar Geldleute, die auch davon profitiert haben, von diesen riesigen Transfersummen, die dann ins Land geflossen sind. Aber von dieser Ausnahme, die ging es saudreckig da unten. Also die hatten vielleicht irgendwie auf dem Papier einen Gutschein, dass sie jetzt im Werte von x palästinänisch empfunden können, sie aus Deutschland was importieren. Aber bis sie das dann zu Geld gemacht haben, also die haben da richtig Hunger gehungert. Und denen ging es überhaupt nicht gut. Und die sind auch von ihren eigenen Leuten, also das geht aus den Akten des Bundesarchivs und des Auswärtigen Amtes ganz klar vor, die sind auch von ihren eigenen Leuten zu ganz schlecht oder überhaupt nicht bezahlten Arbeiten gezwungen worden. Die wussten nicht, was sie da machen sollten. Viele sind dann aus Palästina dann nach Amerika, so wurden USA als eben auch Südamerika weitergewandert, weil die konnten da gar nicht leben.
Deutschland hat ja auch dann dieses Geld, was sie quasi entteuernd hatten, nicht unbedingt ausgezahlt, sondern ist natürlich benutzt, um ihren Krieg zu finanzieren.
Aus der Judenvermögensabgabe, ja, das ist da reingeflassen.
Diese Zusammenarbeit von Eichmann mit den zionistischen Organisationen, die finde ich insofern interessant, als dass der, also was waren denn die Motivationen dahinter? Also was war eigentlich die Motivation der zionistischen Organisationen, mit den Nazis an dieser Stelle zusammenzuarbeiten, die nun doch eigentlich ganz klar sozusagen auf der anderen Seite standen?
Ja, die Zionisten wollten den Staat Israel aufbauen. Das war ein klares Projekt, nur von den Zionisten, die wie gesagt eine Minderheit war, innerhalb der jüdischen Weltbewegung. Und die Nazis wollten Europa und vor allem Deutschland Juden freimachen. Insofern haben die sich da ein gemeinsames Interesse gefunden.
Also du schreibst in dem Buch auch, um mal zu sagen, wie stark diese Kooperation war, dass als in Deutschland und Österreich schon verboten war, den anderen Juden Zeitungen und so zu publizieren, da durften die Zionisten einfach weitermachen. Also das war schon, also nicht nur, das sind unsere Freunde, sondern die waren dann auch von manchen Repersalien nicht betroffen.
Ja natürlich, die verboten wurden, nur die, die nicht Zionisten waren. Und in meiner Eichmann ist ja 1937 nach Palästina, wollte er nach Palästina fahren, um sich mit Leuten der Hageina zu treffen, also Vorläufer des israelischen Geheimdienstes. Und die haben ihm dann versprochen, ja wir arbeiten auch nachrichtendienstlich zusammen, wir werden auch, wenn es um Verteilung von Erdölkonstitutionen geht, an euch denken, die haben sich dann in den Ägypten getroffen, weil er konnte da nicht weiter einreisen und die haben eng zusammengearbeitet.
Also haben die da nicht unglaublich Gegenwind gekriegt von allen anderen Juden? Ich meine, Kollaboration ist ja noch ein zu schönes Wort dafür, was die gemacht haben.
Ich glaube, das Thema ist innerhalb der Juden ein ganz heikles Ding. Ich meine, Kollaboration ist im Grunde ja auch, du machst das ja nicht freiwillig, es ist ja auch eine erzwungene Geschichte.
Ja, also wenn man das vergleicht mit, sagen wir, Frankreich, wie schlecht da über die Kollaborateure geurteilt wird und dass alle nachhinein in der Resistenz waren. Na gut, ich meine, das ist ja eine ganz andere Art, damit umzugehen.
Die historische Perspektive ist natürlich, dass die zionistische Geschichtsschreibung ja sagt, okay, das war halt aus der Not geboren und immerhin haben wir irgendwie viele hunderttausend Leute rausbekommen, die halt nicht in die Lager gewonnen haben. Und deshalb ist ja ihre historische Rechtfertigung dafür, dass sie halt diesen Deal gemacht haben.
Nee, sie haben noch eine andere Rechtfertigung. Sie sagen auch noch dazu, wir hätten ohne den Holocaust hätten wir den Staat Israel. Ohne diesen moralischen Druck wäre der Staat Israel nicht gegründet worden. Es gibt ein ganz gutes Beispiel, wo das nochmal klar würde. Eichmann ist ja 1944 nach Ungarn gegangen, geschickt worden, um dort die jüdischen, die jüdische Bevölkerung zusammenzufassen, zu erfassen und abzutransportieren in die Vernichtungslager. Und er hat dann mitten in dieser Geschichte den Leiter der jüdischen Gemeinde, das waren wir jetzt nicht in zwei Leuten, das war der Rudolf Kastner, mit dem er engstens zusammengearbeitet hat. Und Kastner hat seine eigene Familie gerettet und hat dann die restlichen Juden ordentlich in die Züge transportiert und hat gesagt, meldet euch so schnell wie möglich, ihr kriegt Länder in Osteuropa und wer zuerst kommt, mal zuerst. Und die Züge sind alle ausnahmslos nach Auschwitz gegangen. Und Eichmann hat dann 1944 den Joel Brandt, eben auch ein hoher Funktionär der jüdischen Gemeinde, zu sich gebeten und hat gesagt, pass auf, ich mach euch ein Deal. Es ging dabei um einen separaten Frieden im Grunde. Ich mach euch ein Deal. Ihr gebt mir 100, ihr gebt mir 10.000 Lastwagen und dafür stelle ich eine Million Juden an die Grenze, wo er sie haben wollt. Also ich halt dann sozusagen die Vernichtungsmaschinerie erst mal an. Und dann ist der Joel Brandt, das ist alles dokumentiert in Büchern, der ist dann erst mal nach Istanbul gefahren, zu Ben Gurion. Der saß da mit seiner Jewish Agency. Türkei war ja ein halbwegs neutrales Lamm und hat gesagt, was machen wir, wir müssen doch irgendwie auf dieses Angebot eingehen, um eine Million zu reppen. Und er hat gesagt, nee, es gibt überhaupt keine Möglichkeit und hat ihn dann weiterziehen lassen in den Nahen Osten. Und dann haben die Briten festgesetzt und dann ist er nicht zurück. Und dann hat Eichmann sein Werk sozusagen vollendet und hat fast 500.000 in die Vernichtungslager geschickt. Das ist natürlich, wenn man sich das heute überlegt. Vielleicht ist es sinnvoll, auf dieses Angebot nicht eingegangen zu sein, weil das den Krieg mit Sicherheit verlängert hätte. Aber natürlich, wenn man so ein Angebot hat, verhandelt man doch mit den Leuten und tut so als, haben sie überhaupt nicht gemacht. Und auch Ben Goyon hat sich nicht irgendwie jetzt vor die Weltöffentlichkeit gestellt und das angeprangelt und gesagt, man müsste. Also man hat einfach dann auf das Kriegsende gewartet und gesagt, hier muss, ja, man hat es nicht, es war nicht Priorität.
Also das heißt auf Deutsch, Ben Goyon hat auch nur zu verlieren gehabt, wenn Eichmann aussagt.
Aber wie? Und dann ist ja noch Eichmanns vorgesetzter in der SS-Struktur, der Herr Becher, der dann ein sehr angesehener Geschäftsmann wurde in der Bundesrepublik und Mitglied des Bremer Schaffermals und so, Kurt Becher, den haben die Alliierten festgesetzt. Der war mit ihm zusammen im besetzten Budapest gewesen. Und der stand dann in Nürnberg, sollte eben der Prozess gemacht werden. Und da ist Rudolf Kastner, also der Leiter der jüdischen Gemeinde in Rudolf, ist aus damals noch nicht Israel, aber schon Paläst, ist angereist nach Nürnberg und hat eine Aussage für Herrn Kastner gemacht, dass Herr Kastner so ein toller Typ gewesen wäre, dem es immer nur um das Retten jüdischen Lebens gegangen wäre. Und dann ist der Kastner, dann ist der Becher freigelassen worden und hat eine wunderbare Geschäftskarriere in der Bundesrepublik gemacht. Auch Geschäfte mit Israel. Kastner ist dann in Israel, hat dann jemand das rausgefunden und hat ihn dann öffentlich angegriffen. Und dann gab es ein Gerichtsverfahren. Und dann haben die Richter, als sie das dann erfahren haben, dass er eine Aussage zugunsten von Becher gemacht hat, sozusagen für den Ankläger gesagt hat, das ist ja das Allerletzte. Und dann ist aber, Kastner wollte dann aussagen, wie denn die Zusammenhänge waren. Und dann ist er auf offener Straße von einem Mitglied des Geheimdienstes erschossen worden. Der hat dann auch gesessen, hat seine Strafe auch, relativ geringe Strafe, abgesessen und hat jetzt hinterher gesagt, es hätten noch andere Leute geschossen. Er sei nicht der einzige Schütze gewesen. Also das ist auch eine ganz dubiose Geschichte. Da ist also offensichtlich, ist da auch jemandem das Maul gestopft worden. Auf jeden Fall musste Ben Gourion alles daran setzen, um Eichmann daran zu hindern, auszupacken.
Wie haben sie das denn eigentlich gemacht?
Moment, lassen Sie uns noch mal kurz zu dem Punkt. Wir sind gerade, also die offizielle Geschichte ist ja sowas, dass sie ihn irgendwie, was war es, 12. Mai, 11. Mai oder sowas eingesagt haben und dann noch mal...
11. Mai 1960.
Genau.
Und dann saß er da zehn Tage irgendwie unklar.
Wo wir nicht wissen, wo um.
Und du hattest doch noch diese Geschichte gefunden, dass er schon am 12. Mai seiner Sozialversicherung abgemeldet wurde?
Ja, Mercedes.
Bei Daimler, ne? Ja, genau.
Ja, ja, ja.
Erzähl die doch vielleicht noch mal, weil die find ich zu bizarr.
Ja, ja, der Chef, das war ein gewisser Mossetti und der spielt dann eine ganz große Rolle in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Ein Amerikaner, geboten Italiener, aber dann Amerikaner. Und der, also Mercedes hat ihn am 12. Mai schon aus der Sozialversicherung abgemeldet.
Also einen Tag, nachdem er verschwunden ist, quasi.
Ja, sie hätten ihm so einen Brief schreiben müssen, sie müssen sich hier melden, sonst verlieren sie ihn ab. Haben sie alles nicht gemacht.
Also ich meine, aber gut, er war ja sozusagen erst einen Tag weg zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Ja, aber wenn du als, wenn du Arbeiter bist, normalerweise und du gehst nicht in den Betrieb, dann schickt er automatisch, schickt dir die Personalabteilung, schickt dir einen Brief und sagt, du bist gestern nicht gekommen, wenn du morgen auch nicht kommst, wirst du entlassen.
Ach so, okay.
Das dauert aber zumindest einen Tag, bevor du die Abmeldung machst.
Ja, aber offensichtlich wussten die schon, dass er nicht wiederkommt.
Okay, das heißt also, irgendjemand hat ihn eingesackt und hatte ihn quasi im Eisschrank. Irgendwo. Okay, aber dieser Atomtest war ja erst sehr viel später. Der war erst zehn Tage später.
Ja.
Okay. Und wie?
Hat auch da mit der Eichmann Geschichte nichts zu tun.
Das war also parallel.
Also komplett parallele Handlungsstränge. Genau.
Okay, aber jetzt fliegt den Amis, dieses Erdbeben um die Ohren.
Die Frage ist ja, wie hat ihn dann eigentlich zuerst eingesackt? Weil darauf läuft es ja dann am Ende hinaus.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Wollen wir jetzt die Figur von Lotte Herrmann, wollen wir die hier jetzt einbringen?
Ja.
Ja, es gibt ja auch irgendwie Leute, die wirklich denen nicht gut mitgespielt worden ist. Die tragischste Figur eigentlich. Ja, Lotte Herrmann ist ein jüdischer Immigrant gewesen, der dann auch erblindet ist. Und er war ein Nachbar von Adolf Eichmann und hat den Wohnort von Eichmann schon dem Frankfurter Generalstaatsverwalt Fritz Bauer 1957 mitgeteilt.
Ein Dachrau-Überlebendes war, ne?
Er war auch schon hier 1936 in Dachrau gewesen, wegen Spienage und Devisenschmuggel, ja. Er war hier auch schon, konnte sich gerade noch mal so retten. Seine Familie, die nicht flüchten konnte, die ist in Auschwitz und Buchen weitermordet worden. Er ist dann in Argentinien, wie gesagt, er hat dann den Eichmann angezeigt und hatte auch Briefe geschrieben. Ich habe die Briefe, ich kenne die Familie ganz gut. Und er wollte dann Operationen draus machen gegen Eichmann, bestand ja ab 1956 auch schon Hofbefehl, einer der wenigen Nazis, die mit Hofbefehl gesucht wurden. Und er hat dann auch mit der jüdischen Gemeinde in Buenos Aires Kontakte gehabt und hat die doch bei sich zu Hause empfangen. Wir müssen da was tun, wir müssen was machen. Und es wusste die halbe argentinische Linke wusste auch, dass da Eichmann gesucht der Nazi war und jeder weiß, wo er ist. Und die jüdische Gemeinde wussten das alle.
Du schreibst in dem Buch, dass als der Eichmann dann entführt wurde, die einzige Presse in Argentinien, die nicht darüber berichtet hat, irgendwie die kommunistische Presse.
Genau.
Das ist ja auch alles unglaublich, oder?
Ja, ich gehe davon aus, dass die Operation ursprünglich mal geplant worden ist von der jüdischen Gemeinde und der kommunistischen Partei und dass sie dann anders verlaufen ist.
Okay.
Aber das ist ein Punkt, der ist noch offen. Und ich denke, wir sollten uns, es gibt so viele Sachen, die nicht auf der Spekulationsebene sind, lassen wir es einfach mal, es wird irgendwann auch rauskommen.
Okay, also es gibt sozusagen diese zehn Tage oder zwölf Tage, wo Eichmann weg ist und dann gibt es diese Mossad-Geschichte, dass sie ihn angeblich eingesagt hätten und dann hätten sie noch eine Weile in einem Haus gehabt und irgendwie haben ihn dann in ein Flugzeug gebracht.
Nein, im Buch wird erwähnt, dass der Generalanwalt von Israel nicht wusste, dass Eichmann kommt, bevor er bisher im Flugzeug saß. Also das heißt, die 10 Tage wusste auch niemand in Israel, dass er jetzt kommt. Auch der Mossad nicht. Du hattest da irgendwie auch irgendwelche Sachen.
Das muss man alles abwarten. Auf jeden Fall wussten die Argentinen, die israelischen Behörden nicht, dass Eichmann sozusagen... Wahrscheinlich wussten sie es wirklich nicht. Wahrscheinlich wusste es Ben Goyon auch nicht. Was hätte denn Ben Goyon mit dem gemacht, wenn es in Chile nicht gerumst hätte?
Dann ein Flugzeugunfall, oder?
Hätte er, ja, oder vielleicht hätte er in Chile aufgeschlitzt und auf den Thaïa-Platz nach Cairo gelegt, um auch noch die Ägypter zu beschuldigen, dass sie die Nazis da bei sich haben. Weiß man alles nicht. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass er vor Gericht gelandet wäre.
Also du gehst schon davon aus, dass ihnen zumindest entweder die Amerikaner oder die Israelis einen gesagt haben.
Ich glaube, dass ihnen Argentinier, um eine Propaganda-Aktion zu machen, überredet haben, mitzugehen. Und dass er dann von argentinischer Polizei befreit worden ist.
Befreit worden ist?
Du kannst doch nicht einfach jemanden entführen in Argentinien. Es gibt noch eine Polizei in Argentinien. Das geht so nicht.
Okay. Und dann?
Und dann muss es irgendeine Übergabe gegeben haben.
Also du meinst, der wurde in Argentinien von irgendjemanden eingesagt, der da eine Propaganda-Aktion draus machen wollte.
Vergiss nicht, dass am 16. Mai 1960 das Gipfeltreffen in Paris stattgefunden hat von Eisenhower und Khrustchev, wo es um Teststop ging.
Genau, das haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt, worum es da eigentlich ging.
Und Khrustchev wollte ein neutrales Gesamtdeutschland mit freien Wahlen und entnazifiziert vorschlagen.
Und quasi als Entnazifizierung macht man so, hätte er dann Eichmann hingelegt, oder? Das wäre perfekt gewesen.
Ich hab da, gefällt mir gerade an, ich hab ungefähr im Dachboden bei uns in meinem alten Haus noch zu DDR-Zeiten ein altes Transparent gefunden für eine freie und entmilitarisierte Stadt Berlin. Für eine vereinigte und entmilitarisierte Stadt Berlin.
Das war der Vorstadt von Holbrich und Khrustchev. Ja, genau.
Irgendwann war das 57, 58 oder so.
Ja, das war in der Zeit. Genau. Und das wollten die ganz groß rausbringen am 16. Mai 1960. Und das war ganz klar. Was hätte denn, sagen wir doch mal, ganz realistisch, wenn sich Eichmann gestellt hätte, im Mai 1960. Gut, es gab gegen ihn den Haftbefehl. Er hat, wirft ihm niemand vor, dass er mit eigenen Händen jemanden umgebracht hat. Er hat die Transporte gemacht. Was wäre denn sein vorgesetzter Becher, war erfolgreicher Geschäftsmann, Herr Glockke saß im Kanzleramt, in allen anderen Behörden saßen auch seine Kumpels. Was wäre ihm denn passiert? Vielleicht hätte er in Deutschland, wenn er in Deutschland vor Gericht gelandet wäre, vielleicht hätte er drei Jahre bekommen. Das ist noch fünf, alles fünf Jahre vor dem Auschwitzprozess gewesen, wo sie die schlechter sozusagen verfolgt haben. Und er saß da, der hat diese Transporte gemacht.
Das ist auch noch so ein Detail, was ich sehr spannend finde, weil in der, in der, so was man in der Schule lernt, ist Eichmann ja der Architekt des Holocaust. Er ist so fast im Alleingang.
Der Einzelpäter.
Ja, im Grunde, ja, das ist genau der Punkt, auf den ich hinaus will, dass eben im Grunde die, die Israel in diesem Verfahren diese Legende geschaffen hat, dass wir jetzt, wo wir den Eichmann verfolgt haben, können wir im Grunde aufhören, weil er war der Wichtige.
Ja, und es wird, in dieser Legende wird auch Eichmann in seiner argentinischen Zeit auch noch so gezeichnet, als wäre er in Argentinien auch noch der Antisemit gewesen. Das ist völliger Unsinn. Ich kenne ja Leute aus dem Betrieb, die mit ihm zusammengearbeitet haben, aus dem Stadtviertel. Eichmann hat wunderbar mit den, also ganz normal mit den jüdischen Nachbarn da, da hatte er jetzt Kontakte. Eichmann hatte auch Kontakte zur jüdischen Gemeinde der Daya. Die waren mit ihm, das ist ja auch verständlich von deren Perspektive aus. Da ist jemand und der redet seit 1956 mit dem Wilhelm Sassen und macht seine Lebensbeichte und er hat eine Menge zu sagen und der weiß sehr viel. Den willst du doch auch nachrichtendienstlich abschöpfen, wie man das so sagen würde. Und warum soll die jüdische Gemeinde nicht auch für Israel diesen Mann abgeschöpft haben? Das macht Sinn.
Du hast noch so ein Memo, ich weiß nicht mehr welcher Geheimdienst es war, aber da ging es um das Gerücht, dass er ja für den Mossad arbeiten würde, weil er ja so wunderbar mit diesen Israelis kann, mit den Juden, die da wohnen.
Er hat die beste Beziehung zu hohen jüdischen Mitgliedern der Gemeinde. Das ist bewiesen inzwischen. Und sie haben nichts gemacht. Sie haben natürlich von ihm Informationen haben wollen. Das ist klar. Hat er ja auch gegeben.
Okay, so jetzt mal wieder die Chronologie ein wenig hereinbringen, damit unsere Hörer nicht komplett verwirrt werden. So was heißt also, deine Theorie ist, wo noch ein bisschen die Belege fehlen, sagtest du gerade.
Ja, es gibt natürlich noch viele weiße Flecken.
Von diesen zehn Tagen.
Von diesen zehn Tagen im Wesentlichen. Ich habe da eine Theorie, aber wie gesagt...
Wenn man sie nicht belegen kann, muss man sie ja nicht...
Genau, genau. Also das weiß man immer noch nicht. Was gut belegt ist, ist alles, was dann in Israel mit dem Prozess gelaufen ist. Es ist alles sehr gut belegt, was mit der Operation Geschäftsfreund gelaufen ist. Es ist ja dann gezahlt worden, nicht 2 Milliarden im Mark, sondern 630 über die Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau.
Die geleitet wurde von diesem Abt, war das nicht so?
Kriegsverbrecher, den haben sie ja noch, die Alliäten haben ihn als Kriegsverbrecher...
Die die Arisierung durchgeführt haben.
Für die Deutsche Bank.
Unter den Nazis, also eine lupenreine Karriere.
Das war die Vertrauensperson von Adenauer, die auch die Bundesrepublik bei der Londoner Schuldenkonferenz vertreten hat. Ganz offiziell. Übrigens, diese Dinge würde ich gerne auch mal aus der Sicht der Bank sehen, weil, ich meine, Abs hat die Bundesrepublik ganz offiziell vertreten bei der Londoner Schuldenkonferenz. Dann hat er ganz offiziell die Bundesrepublik vertreten beim Wiedergutmachungsabkommen. Dann hat er laut Unterlagen des Auswärtigen Amtes die Operation Geschäftsfreund mit Details ausgestattet. Das alles sind ja Sachen, die hat er im Auftrag der Bundesregierung gemacht. Wo sind diese Unterlagen? Ich weiß, wo sie liegen. Die liegen im Historischen Institut der Deutschen Bank. Und die Deutsche Bank, die gibt diese Unterlagen, lässt Leute, denen sie vertraut und dass sie auch in ihrem Interesse dann schreiben, da einsehen. Ich habe also einen Antrag gestellt bei diesem Institut, bei der Deutschen Bank, aber ich möchte diese gerne einsehen. Wobei mich ja nur die Dokumente interessieren, die er im Auftrag der Behörden, also der Regierung gemacht hat. Was er da mit seiner Sekretärin oder was er für die Deutsche Bank macht, das ist sein Privatding.
Sollten die nicht im Bundesarchiv liegen?
Ja, es ist ja behördliches Material. Es gibt Abgabepflichten der Behörden. Diese Sachen müssen eigentlich im Bundesarchiv liegen. Ebenso zum Beispiel wie der Nachlass von Herrn Globke, der ja immer Staatsbeabter war, sei es im Reichsinnenministerium unter Hitler oder sei es als Staatsminister für Herrn Adenauer und Leiter des Bundes- und Aufsichtsbehörde vom Bundesnachrichtendienst. Und die Sachen von ihm, der Nachlass, liegt in der Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung. Und auch da habe ich um Einsicht gebeten und da hieß es zuerst grundsätzlich nein, sie nicht, andere Forscher haben da sehr schöne Einsicht bekommen. Zum Schluss haben sie mir dann etwas gezeigt, auch nicht alles. Und ich habe dann das Bundesarchiv aufgefordert, ich möchte diese Akten haben. Das ist, ich habe sogar eine Strafverzeiger gestellt gegen die Deutsche Bank und gegen die Adenauer-Stiftung wegen Hehlerei. Ist natürlich sofort eingestellt worden. Und dann hat die Deutsche, hat mir das Bundesarchiv in Koblenz zurückgeschrieben, hat gesagt, ja, sie bedauern das auch sehr, diese Privatisierung. Das handelt sich hierbei um Bundesarchivmaterial, die gehören eigentlich ins Bundesarchiv, wo sie dann allen Forschern zur Verfügung stehen. Unabhängig, ob du die CDU wählst oder ob du was anderes wählst. Aber sie hätten eben keine Möglichkeiten, da was zu machen. Und dann habe ich sie jetzt verklagt vor dem Verwaltungsgericht. Ich habe die erste Instanz schon verloren. Die zweite Instanz wird übermorgen entschieden. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich die auch verlieren werde. Es ist einfach ein Untertanengeist in Deutschland. Sie bestimmen, wo sie ihr Herrschaftswissen einbunkern. Und dann bestimmen sie, wer es kriegt. Du unterschreibst ja dann auch, du musst es dir dann vorlegen, bevor es dann veröffentlicht. Sie bestimmen damit die Linie. Und es gibt keine Aktenöffentlichkeit. Selbst bei offensichtlichem Verstoß, dass die Leute einfach ihr Zeug mit nach Hause nehmen. Ich meine, wenn es ihnen so ans Herz gewachsen ist, können sie sich ja eine Kopie machen. Aber die nehmen das einfach mit, die Originale. Ich hab dann bei der Adenauer Stiftung die wenigen Sachen, die sie mir haben einsehen lassen. Das ist alles, es waren auch streng geheime Sachen. Das sind Sachen, wie Verkehr mit dem Bundeskanzler, die gehören im Bundesarchiv. Und der Zug ist geregelt durch das Bundesarchivgesetz.
Also so eine Szene, wie du am Anfang in Argentinien beschrieben hast, dass die mit dir und einem Brechstange losgehen, ist hier undenkbar.
Das Bundesarchiv, das sind alles treue Beamte ihrer Kanzlerin.
Könnten die denn, wenn sie wollten und wollen nur nicht? Oder können die wirklich nicht?
Was hindert sie denn daran, zum Beispiel einen Brief zu schreiben an die Deutsche Bank und zu sagen, liebe Deutsche Bank, wir wissen, ihr habt da die und die Materialien. Können wir da nicht eine Kopie oder behaltet doch die Kopie. Schickt uns doch die ganzen Dinge, die uns betreffen, die hierher gehören. Die machen gar nichts. Die setzen auf ihrem Arsch.
Haben sie denn da einen Hebel oder wäre das eine Bittstellung?
Also, weißt du, wenn mir das Finanzamt schickt mir einen Bescheid und da steht drin, du musst jetzt 12,50 Euro zahlen, wenn ich die nicht zahle, kriege ich irgendwann mal Ärger. Ich weiß nicht, wie das läuft. Kommt dann der Gerichtsvollzieher? Genau. Also, ich meine, die Bundesbehörde muss doch die gesetzliche Grundlage, die gesetzliche Bestimmung irgendwie durchsetzen können. Warum schickt sie nicht die Polizei dahin?
Hast du dann eigentlich mal bei den Russen gefragt?
Oh ja.
Gab es da irgendeine Antwort oder haben die...
Ich habe die ganze Palette... Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die überhaupt ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz haben. Haben die sowas?
Ich glaube, es gibt da irgendwelche komischen Historiker und Archivgesetze, aber irgendwie...
Man könnte sich immer auf die Verfassung beziehen, im Grunde. Aber ist auch eher, ich habe das versucht und das Einzige, die überhaupt geantwortet haben, war das Außenministerium. Und die haben dann gesagt, sie hätten nichts zu dem, was ich will.
Und der KGB wollte den nicht antworten?
Hat gar nicht geantwortet.
Die haben wahrscheinlich eine Flasche Wodka geöffnet und sich gesagt, guck mal, was wir für einen schönen Brief gekriegt haben.
Hänge zu den anderen, den Rahmen, den Flur.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich verstehe es nicht. Also diese ganzen Geschichten da, die mit diesen unterirdischen Atomen versuchen, die haben sie doch alle mitgekriegt. Die sind doch nicht an ihnen vorbeigegangen. Der stand ja auch in der argentinischen Presse, als da diese ganzen Atomwaffen da mit den Riesenflugzeugen gekommen sind. Das stand da in der Zeitung, die haben es alle mitgekriegt. Es ist doch alles, die haben Abkommen mit den USA im Moratorium. Das wird ganz vulgär brutal gebrochen. Warum haben die das nie an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht? Gut, die Russen haben ihre eigenen Geschichten auch mit diesen dektonischen Waffen, mit dem zivilen Gebrauch von Atomwaffen gemacht. Natürlich haben die das auch gemacht, aber in der konkreten Situation.
Vielleicht, mein gut, das Wetter nennen wir ja diese zivile Gebrauch von Atomwaffen ja doch noch relativ lange popularisiert. Also bis hin dazu, dass sie das sogar noch in den 70ern irgendwann getan haben, dass sie da Erdgaslagerstätten miteinander verbunden haben durch Atomwaffeneinsatz.
Ja und Flussläufe auch und so.
Ja na gut, das war noch ein bisschen früher. Also da gibt es ja diesen Totensee, der aus der Luft sehr beeindruckend aussieht. Das ist halt so ein See von genau so einem Versuch. Und da ist halt die Strahlung immer noch so hoch, dass da genau nichts lebt. Deswegen ist das Wasser strahlend blau. Und die...
Da kommt das Wort strahlend blau.
Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sie halt einfach keine Lust hatten, ihre eigene Taktik dabei zu diskreditieren. Und dass die Amis ihren Willen, das auszunutzen, einfach schlicht überschätzt haben.
Ja, oder es gibt natürlich auch überhaupt keine Tradition der Eröffnung der Archive, dass ich meine, Herr Putin kommt vom KGB. Ich würde es mir ja auch... Also natürlich macht man als Forscher, macht man immer diese Anträge, aber so viel habe ich mir ja auch nicht davon versprochen. Ich finde es eigentlich schade.
Also was vielleicht mal lohnen könnte, wäre mal bei den Briten zu fragen, die am Etrosch gehen haben. Diesen KGB-Archiv war, der unter den Dielen seiner Datscher über 30 oder 40 Jahre hinweg Ex-Sapta aus Akten, handschriftliche gesammelt hat. Und der dann irgendwann die den Amis angeboten hat, dafür, dass sie ihn und seine Familie rausholen, so 91 oder so, oder 90. Und die Amis haben es halt verkackt und dann haben wir die Briten rausgeholt. Und dann gibt es also zwei Bände, die der geschrieben hat, dann mit dem H-Geografer vom MI5, die Mitroschkern-Archive. Und die haben zumindest ein bisschen Kram. Also da lohnt es möglicherweise mal nachzufragen.
Naja, also was hier jetzt passieren muss, wie geht es jetzt weiter? Und in den USA ist ja eigentlich, ich habe in den USA natürlich diese ganzen Anträge jetzt auf Akteneinsicht. Und es gibt in den USA, und das war eine große Errungenschaft der Bürgerrechtsbewegung. Und die Demokraten haben das damals war Bill Clinton noch auch, der hat das auch mit durchgesetzt. Dieses Gesetz des Nazi War Crimes Disclosure Act, also das alles, was mit Nazi-Kriegsverbrechen zu tun hat, alles veröffentlicht werden muss. Ich habe, wie gesagt, ich habe den Antrag gestellt zu dem Interviewer von dem Eichmann, der sassen, der in CIA-Spitze war. Das steht im, also das ist ja für die US-Botschaft gearbeitet, das steht in den BND-Unterlagen so drinnen. Zu den ganzen Sachen habe ich Anträge gestellt, auch zu der Helms, also Richard Helms, der war danach kurz in Argentinien und hat mit seinen Kollegen vom Argentinischen Geheimdienst, die Berichte habe ich auch.
Der musste dann aufräumen hinterher.
Die haben Gastgeschenke ausgetauscht, haben so riesen Steaks gegessen. Da war er ganz begeistert von, der Herr Helms. Diese ganzen Sachen habe ich beantragt und habe mich auch auf dieses Gesetz bezogen. Der CIA hat gesagt, du kriegst ja auch von uns nichts mehr, jetzt ist ja Schluss. Dann habe ich diese Sachen an das Justizministerium geschickt, in den USA. Ich kenne die, ich habe da immer gearbeitet. Die haben gesagt, das geht nicht, das ist illegal, das können die nicht machen. Dann habe ich gesagt, das finde ich aber schön. Hier ist der Schriftwechsel, macht ihr was, das sind eure Behörden. Dann haben sie nach ein paar Wochen gesagt, ja es wäre jetzt alles sehr schwierig, aber sie wünschen mir Goodluck. Ja super, super. Dann habe ich mit diesen Entnahmeblättern, mit den Whistleroll-Sheets einiges habe ich da sogar bekommen. Sie geben zu, dass sie diese Atombomben quer durch die Welt geschickt haben und und und. Aber viele Sachen sind nach wie vor geheim. CIA sagt, ich kriege keine Auskunft, weil ich nicht die Staatsbürgerschaft habe. Das läuft auf dem Verfahren, auf dem Prozess jetzt hinaus. Das ist ja gegen die CIA noch relativ einfach, weil da gilt das Freedom of Information Gesetz, also das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und eben auch dieses Nazi Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Die Sachen, die in den Präsidentenbibliotheken liegen, da gilt es aber nicht. Das haben sie rausgenommen, extra rausgenommen. Da kann man auch klagen, aber das ist alles komplizierter. Aber sie haben ja noch nicht mal eine Ablehnung geschickt. Ich schreibe dann ja auch immer alle drei Monate, schreibe ich ans Pentagon und schreibe an Department of Energy, also vor allem Department of Energy, da verspreche ich mir was von, da liegen die Sachen. Schreibe ich dann hin und sage ich, ja wie ist es jetzt? Ich habe jetzt seit zwei Jahren den Antrag zu laufen, könnt ihr mal entscheiden. Und dann schreiben sie ganz freundlich immer zurück und sagen, ja sie sind am Bearbeiten und ich muss noch ein bisschen Geduld haben. Es muss eine politische Entscheidung jetzt treffen, getroffen werden.
Was wahrscheinlich vor den Wahlen nicht mehr passiert.
Ach man weiß ja nicht, man weiß ja nicht, was da läuft. Im Grunde, was würde denn Obama verlieren? Es ist eine Eisenhauer-Geschichte gewesen. Kennedy hat dann damit ein bisschen aufgeräumt. Er hat Ploshair zwar weitergeführt, aber zumindest hat er es dann nicht mehr im Ausland gemacht. Und was würde er denn verlieren?
Na es gibt dann noch dieses peinliche Detail, dass die Versuche nach US-Recht illegal waren. Also, dass die Ploshair-Dings, weil sie die Waffen gar nicht erst nach Argentinien hätte bringen dürfen, weil die diese Safe-Gards nicht unterschrieben haben.
Ja, es gibt das Energy Act von 1954, das man studieren sollte. Und da steht drin, dass sie nur zusammenarbeiten können mit anderen Nationen, wenn es der eigenen Verteidigung dient. Also zum Beispiel gedacht ist dann, dass man mit den Briten zusammenarbeitet oder so. Oder im Rahmen der NATO. Nur war Argentinien überhaupt keine Militärbündnis und eigentlich eher noch kurz zuvor ein Schorkenstaat gewesen. Also es gab keine Begründung und es gab auch keine militärische Bedrohung. Was ist da in Puerto de Ciudad? Da sind ein paar wildgewordene Pinguine. Was macht man da mit Atomwaffen? Es gibt dafür keine Begründung. Und nur weil eine private Firma einen Kanal bauen will und weniger Geld für die Lastwagen und die Schuttabtragungen ausgeben will, das ist keine Begründung, die im Energy Act von 1954 vorgesehen ist. Also so ganz legal ist das alles nicht. Nichtsdestotrotz, das ist ewig lang her. Ich weiß nicht, was in den USA immer noch nach 50 Jahren geheim gehalten werden. Die haben schon ganz andere Sachen freigegeben. Es läuft jetzt darauf hinaus, dass ich jetzt klagen muss. Ich werde das auch tun. Ich habe ja Anwälte in den USA, die mich vertreten in den anderen Sachen. Das wird jetzt laufen. Das ist jetzt der nächste Schritt. Ich kann mir aber vorstellen, dass vielleicht auch noch die Regierung es doch noch freigibt. Das Auswärtige Amt hat ja fast alles freigegeben.
Wie ist denn das dann sonst in Deutschland? Also der BND hat dir ja Akten geschickt. Bist du damit zufrieden?
Ich habe die einklagen müssen.
Ja, aber jetzt haben sie ja was geschickt, aber da gab es ja auch Probleme, oder nicht?
Ja, sie haben was geschickt, aber sie kopieren dann so schlecht, dass man das nicht lesen kann. Und wie gesagt, 100 Blatt werden vom Kanzleramt immer noch frei der Offenlegung vorenthalten und das Bundesverwaltungsgericht hat das abgesegnet. Also wir wissen zu Adolf Eichmann immer noch nicht alles in Deutschland.
Meinst du, das wird sich noch klären oder ist das jetzt halt verloren?
Na, also ich glaube, mit Frau Merkel wird sich das nicht klären. Frau Merkel tut immer das, was man ihr sagt und sie dreht ihr Fähnchen immer dahin, wo der Wind gerade her weht. Und sie möchte sich eben nicht mit Israel anlegen und auch nicht mit den USA. Und ich glaube, sie von irgendwie demokratischen Grundrechten weiß nicht, ob sie davon schon mal was gehört hat. Also ich glaube, mit Aktenoffenlegung, das ist nicht das Ding. Und ich sehe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht in Deutschland irgendeine Öffentlichkeit, die das nun einfordert. Also gibt es Leute, gibt es große Medien, die sagen, jetzt hier, hier muss mal, das muss hier jetzt mal auf den Tisch, dass der Glockennachlass von einem Privatunternehmen, von der Adenauer Stiftung, verwaltet wird, geheim gehalten wird und nur denen gezeigt wird, die der Adenauer Stiftung in den Kram passen. Es ist unsäglich. Das hat mit dem Geist von Demokratie, von demokratischen Entscheidungsstrukturen überhaupt nichts zu tun. Ich bin mir sicher, dass ich den Prozess hier in Deutschland verlieren werde. Ich ziehe ihn auch durch, durch alle Instanzen. Und notfalls gehe ich da auch in der Straßburg. Da wollen wir mal gucken, ob Straßburg das auch richtig findet. Entweder das ist hier eine Demokratie, oder sie sagen, ja in der Monarchie war das auch so. Dann machen wir das so. Ja, kann man ja sagen. Dann sag aber gleich, du verscheißerst die Leute. Du erzählst ihnen das, was den Geheimdiensten in den Kram passt, worauf man sich irgendwann mal geeinigt hat. Und auch wenn es noch so unlogisch ist, du verscheißerst die Leute anders. Aber dann sagt das. Das ist okay. Dann hör ich auf zu klagen.
Also Schlussfolgerand kann man sagen, das Ziel ist eigentlich, dass sie den ganzen Scheiß mal offenlegen. Also wir brauchen auch so ein Gesetz, dass Sachen automatisch nach 30 Jahren offen sind, oder? Das brauchen wir nicht.
Das Gesetz haben wir doch schon.
Na, da sind doch zig Ausnahmen drin und dass man auch noch zahlen muss dafür, dass die einem dann die Sachen offenlegen. Also das ist ja, ich hatte bisher den Eindruck, dass das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in Deutschland eher so ein Papiertiger ist, den sie gemacht haben, damit sie zeigen können, wir haben ja auch so ein Gesetz. Aber es ist nicht wirklich hilfreich in der Praxis.
Naja, das Bundesarchivgesetz ist noch ein anderes Gesetz und das sagt, nach 30 Jahren ist Schluss. Sie halten trotzdem eben noch die Sachen geheim. Das gilt für den kleinen Krisenstab, 1977 Stammheim und es gilt eben für Adolf Eichmann. Und es gilt wahrscheinlich für ganz viele andere Sachen, wo einfach niemand klagt. Weil wo sind denn die Leute, die jetzt hier den Gerichten die Bude einrennen? Ist ja auch nicht der Fall. Und auch die Medien tun sich ja damit abfinden.
Medien finde ich ein gutes Stichwort. Wieso liest man denn Enthüllungen wie die deinen nicht beim Spiegel oder in der Welt?
Ich kann dir genau sagen, was der Spiegel ist. In meinem Verfahren habe ich ja Akteneinsicht, sonst würde ich das ja nicht erfahren. Aber in dem Verfahren gegen das Bundesarchiv, die ich ja wegen Untätigkeit verklagt habe, weil sie das zulassen mit der Deutschen Bank und der Adenauer Stiftung, stelle ich dann fest, dass das Bundesarchiv in meines Falles sich keines, also wirklich in keinster Weise um die Bereitstellung dieser Akten bemüht hat. Nicht mal beim Kanzleramt. Und dann stellt nach meiner Sendung, die habe ich im Deutschlandfond gemacht, die hat wohl der Spiegel-Redakteur auch gehört, und er stellt dann zwei Wochen später, stellt dann andere am Bundesarchiv, und da tut sich dann plötzlich das Bundesarchiv bewegen und stellt beim Bundeskanzleramt nun so einen Antrag. Ich habe dem Kollegen dann vom Spiegel eine E-Mail geschrieben, aber wissen sie was, richtig kollegial ist das ja nicht. Wir sind uns hier einig, das ist mein Antrag. Und er sagt, wir sind von uns keineswegs einig. Das heißt, es gibt eine Bevorzugung von bestimmten Medien, vom Bundesarchiv und von anderen Bundesbehörden, und das ist die Bildzeitung und das ist der Spiegel.
Bei dem, was Sie wissen, dass Sie ihm Interesse berichten?
Naja, ich denke mal, dass wir zwei Faktoren haben. Zum einen werden sich da einigermaßen sicher sein, dass wenn es wirklich eklig ist, dass man da halt immer noch Strippen ziehen kann, und zum anderen ist es halt so, dass Sie da natürlich im Zweifel eine größere Menge Straß und Ärger erwarten, als jetzt von dir, was jetzt irgendwie...
Wenn Sie es nicht rausgeben.
Wenn Sie sich halt gar nichts tun.
Gut, aber das ist jetzt ja auch unsere Aufgabe, da mal ein bisschen Sturm zu machen.
Klar.
Also liebe Hörer.
Ja, und ich meine, man muss diese Rechte auch einklagen.
Das geht nur so lange, wie wir das tun.
Ja, aber ich meine, lass uns mal auf eine allgemeine Geschichte kommen. Wir haben hier das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und wir haben das Bundesarchivgesetz. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ist abgesehen davon, dass es tausend Fehler hat, aber das nimmt von vornherein die Geheimdienste aus. Das Bundesarchivgesetz nicht, aber das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz schon. Also ich meine, erstens...
Also außer einigen Ländern, also in Berlin zum Beispiel, gibt es zumindest ein theoretisches Einblickerecht in die Akten des Verfassungsschutzes, also in deine Akten des Verfassungsschutzes.
Das sind personenbezogene Sachen. Das ist, wenn du wissen willst, was der Verfassungsschutz......
über dich hat, genau, aber halt größere vorgänge sind davon ausgerechnet.
Historiker ist ja ungeeignet, ne?
Ja.
Ja, aber was machen denn die Historiker? Tja. Die halten doch auch ihre Schnurze.
Ich hab so ein bisschen immer den Eindruck, so dass die, dass der, der Wille genau zu verstehen, was in der Vergangenheit passiert ist, bei vielen Leuten, auch bei vielen Journalisten, nicht so richtig ausgeprägt ist. Also so einfach dieser, dieser Biss, zu sagen, okay, ich hab hier was gelernt in der Schule und ich hab's in der Wikipedia gelesen, in der Tagesschau gesehen und im Spiegel gelesen.
Jetzt gucken wir doch mal, ob das stimmt.
Aber ist denn das, was wirklich passiert ist, also ist das nicht nur eine Fiktion, auf die wir uns geeinigt haben, weil sie bequem ist und das Weltbild nicht in Frage stellt, so oder wollen wir uns dann wirklich mal mit den dreckigen Details auseinandersetzen und auch den Motivationen der Leute, wieso sie dreckige Deals gemacht haben oder wieso sie halt in bestimmten Situationen in bestimmte Art und Weise gehandelt haben, weil nur daraus können wir eigentlich wieder was lernen für die Zukunft, weil aus den geschönten Geschichten, die wir präsentiert bekommen, da kann ich ja Ich kann persönlich wenig lernen. Daraus kann ich auch keine Folgerungen daraus ziehen, wie Leute in einer Extremsituation in der Zukunft handeln werden. Dieser Biss fehlt halt einfach. Gerade im Spiegel, wenn man da so die geschichtliche Artikel liest, da hat man immer dieses Problem.
Das ist dieser Gido-Knopf-Historiker-Kram.
Ja, dieser Gido-Knopf ist...
Das ist peinlich.
Aber ich finde, der Spiegel ist genauso. Das ist so mein Überbegriff für diese Antworten.
Moment, lass mich meinen Punkt mal machen. Was mir da immer wieder aufstößt, ist, dass die Geschichten zu gut sind. Das passt halt einfach alles zu gut. Es ist alles viel zu plausibel. Es gibt da keine Brüche. Es gibt keine... Ja, also wie auch immer. Alles in so einer logischen, schönen, erzählbaren Geschichte. Natürlich ist das, was wir lesen wollen. Also die guten Geschichten sind halt die, denen man gut folgen kann, deren Komplexitätsgrad nicht zu groß ist, wo wir nicht irgendwie unser Wahrnehmungsvermögen, was wir bereit sind, in einem so Zehnseiter maximal zu lesen, überschreiten. Und die Geschichte, die du erzählst, mit Eichmann und den Atomtests und so, die ist halt schon wieder genau eins drüber. Es ist halt genau wieder schon so ein Punkt, wo die Komplexität des normal lesewilligen, also des Komplexitätserfassungsvermögen überschritten wird. Weil du halt plötzlich drei komplett unterschiedliche Handlungsstränge hast, die in so einem Punkt kulminieren in der Weltgeschichte, von dem man denkt, der ist schon total ausgeleucht und der ist total schon alles gut verstanden. Und plötzlich steht fest, das stimmt ja halt gar nicht. Und jetzt müssen wir uns mit völlig neuen Konzepten und Gedanken auseinandersetzen und den Folgerungen, die daraus passieren.
Na oder wir stellen uns einfach plump hin und sagen, es ist eine Verschwörungstheorie, wie das die Presse ja gerne mal tut. Insbesondere bei dir, wie gehst du denn damit eigentlich um?
Mit was?
Wenn irgendein Redakteur in irgendeinem Blatt in Deutschland schreibt, ja ja, die Weber mit ihren Verschwörungstheorien immer.
Von den Rechten gab es eine Rezension von der Welt. Da kann ich nur sagen, das sind Primitivlinge. Also da muss ich mich auch... Der hat sich dann noch dazu verstiegen zu sagen... Also er versteht ja, Frau Merkel, dass sie die Akten nicht rausgibt. Also damit möchte ich mich eigentlich in Ungarn auseinandersetzen, weil geht ja nicht einen inhaltlich auf die Sachen. Dann hat es in der FAZ eine Besprechung gegeben von Rainer Blasius. Der macht da die Bücherseite. Wobei der Blasius ist eigentlich ein ganz kluger Typ. Der hat nämlich selbst Ende der 90er Jahre, da war er glaube ich schon im Institut für Zeitgeschichte, diese Operation Geschäftsfreund darüber geschrieben. Die ist in den 90er Jahren mal zum Teil angefangen, haben sie das zu deklassifizieren und jetzt. Und er hat damals diese Geschichten gehabt und ich habe jetzt die Rest der Sachen freigekämpft. Aber er weiß das und dem habe ich dann eine E-Mail geschrieben, hat dann auch wieder mit der Verschwörungsgeschichte gekommen. Also wissen Sie was, Herr Kollege? Sie haben die Geschichte damals doch recherchiert. Schreiben Sie doch mal was dazu. Ich habe ihn auch zitiert. Das war ein guter Artikel, den er damals gemacht hat. Können Sie dazu nicht mal was machen oder passt das nicht in der Weltbild rein? Hat er dann nicht mehr geantwortet? Ja, wie nett und so. Du hast nie mehr was gemacht.
Also was mir auch auffällt in diesem Buch, auf 200 Seiten kommen 700 Fußnoten. Also da drängt sich alles andere als der Eindruck auf, dass es hier irgendwelche Fantasiegeschichten sind, sondern da ist ein unglaublicher Aufwand hinter gewesen, diese ganze Scheiße aus zu recherchieren. Kann das eine Zeitung überhaupt machen? Also kann man es überhaupt erwarten von der Presse, so wie die Landschaft heute aussieht, dass irgendeine Zeitung jemand ein paar Jahre abstellt, um so eine Geschichte zu recherchieren?
Also pass auf, ich bin freiberufliche Journalistin. Ich verdiene mir meinen Lebensunterhalt durch irgendwelche Geschichten. Und das sind ganz andere Geschichten. Also ich meine, das, was ein Korrespondent macht, das sind Wahlen in Paraguay oder, was weiß ich, Bergbau in Argentinien oder, was weiß ich, Karneval in Rio. Irgendwie sowas. Und sowas. Damit verdient man sein Geld. Aber wenn du irgendwie es doch ernst meinst mit deinem Job, du willst doch deinen Job auch irgendwie doch auch gut machen. Das kannst du bestimmt nicht bei jedem Thema machen, weil du die Zeit nicht hast. Aber du kannst doch mal Themen nehmen und die außerhalb der ökonomischen Logik recherchieren und einfach mal am Ball bleiben. Ich recherchiere das jetzt zwar schon sehr lange, aber ich mache das ja nicht als Fulltime. Sondern ich mache das nebenher. Wenn ich mal wieder ein paar Tage Zeit habe, dann gehe ich ins Archiv und mache das und mache das und tue das. Ich habe dann aber auch noch andere Geschichten, die ich dann auch noch mit der Reise verbinde oder so. Wenn ich nach Puerto de Ciudad o fahre, dann mache ich dann auch was über die chinesischen Erdölbohrer in Patagonien. Also das muss man dann schon sehen, wie man das dann finanziert kriegt. Aber die können natürlich auch sich zu Themen wenigstens ein paar Themen mal ab und zu mal vorknöpfen und da mal wirklich zu den Originaldokumenten hingehen. Und nicht immer nur die Historiker zum Beispiel, die schreiben immer voneinander ab. Ja, die zitieren, du musst dir mal die Fußnoten angucken. Die zitieren sich immer gegenseitig, aber dass die mal wirklich in die Archive gehen und das Originaldokument sehen und wenn sie es nicht kriegen, dahinter sind und die Freigabe... Ja oder überhaupt mal bitten, die da... Machen sie nicht! Das sind faule Säcke einfach auch. Das ist eine Frage der Bequemlichkeit. Und ich meine, es gibt in Deutschland keine Tradition des investigativen Journalismus. Und es gibt auch nicht die Tradition, Sachen zu hinterfragen und die Regierung für für Lügner zu halten. Da kann man sich natürlich fragen, halten wir die Regierung für Lügner oder halten wir sie nicht für Lügner?
Also was ich ja so ein bisschen beobachte, ist, dass in den letzten Jahren sich ja dieser Trend so ein bisschen zumindest nicht wendet, aber es zumindest nicht mehr viel schlimmer wird. Also dass zumindest noch mal so einzelne isolierte Inseln von investigativen Journalismus gibt. Also durchaus getrieben durch Wikileaks sicherlich, aber auch durch Leute wie dich, die halt einfach zeigen, dass es geht. Also dass man halt einfach Geschichten finden kann. Meinst du, dass man, dass sich dieses Blatt noch weiter wenden kann? Also es gibt halt so einzelne Leute, was ist jetzt wie den Zastrober der FRS zum Beispiel, der sich dann halt in so ein Thema richtig reinkniet wie diese Odenwaldschule zum Beispiel oder so einzelne Leute beim Spiegel, die halt sich dann wirklich auch in so ein Thema festbeißen und dann immer wieder dazu Sachen machen. Aber es sind halt wirklich so keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich, wenn man die alle in eine Tonhalle sperren würde, wäre immer noch viel Platz, so wie wenn man mal eine Party veranstalten wollte mit allen unterschiedlichen Journalisten in Deutschland. Aber meinst du, dass das ist ja, dass sich da was tut, dass sich da was ändert oder?
Das sind im Grunde die einzigen Geschichten, die sich lohnen, sie zu lesen. Alles andere kannst du wirklich in der Pfeife rauchen. Aber das sind eher Ausnahmen und die große, ja, die Tendenz ist ganz, ganz furchtbar. Erstens kannst du davon nicht mehr leben, weil auch im Journalismus die Honorare sind so gering geworden, dass du davon eigentlich nicht mehr leben kannst. Und wenn du dann dir auch noch den Luxus erlaubst, dann wirklich mal Monate oder vielleicht sogar Jahre in so ein Thema zu investieren, das kannst du eigentlich nicht machen. Du kannst das nur als Hobby oder als irgendwie, ja, du beißt dich dann halt mal fest.
Du steckst ein Steckenpferd sozusagen.
Genau, ja. Und die Sachen sind dann, wenn du liest das dann an von anderen Kollegen und die sind klasse dann, diese Sachen. Aber insgesamt ist nicht... Aber das Problem ist eben auch, die Leute sind überhaupt noch in der Lage, zum Beispiel mal einen Artikel zu lesen, der über fünf Seiten geht.
Da bin ich übrigens tatsächlich nicht so pessimistisch wie viele andere und ich hab tatsächlich...
Vor allem wegen Alternativlos, ne?...
auch Datenmaterial dafür. Zum einen sehen wir, dass unsere langen Sendungen sind die, die am besten laufen. So, also wir haben bei langen Sendungen haben wir überproportional hohe Download-Zahlen und auch eine Menge Feedback von Leuten, die sagen, super, endlich mal ein Thema richtig ausführlich. Zum anderen ist es auch so, dass mir gerade auch die Leute aus der Presse, also aus den Wochenzeitungen insbesondere sagen, die Leute wollen nicht jeden Tag so eine lange Story, aber zumindest zum Wochenende oder zumindest einmal in der Woche. Und da lesen sie dann eben auch lieber eine lange Geschichte als irgendwie diesen kurzen, bunten DPA Printout-Salat, der irgendwie die Presse dominiert. Und wenn man sich auch gerade so die amerikanische Presse anguckt, so weit experimentiert er damit durchaus, dass die auch mal wieder richtig lange Geschichten machen, also richtig so viele Seiten, die halt sich einem Thema widmen. Und das Feedback, was die darauf bekommen, ist, dass offensichtlich eine Menge Leser gibt, die sowas wiederentdecken, also die gerade einfach auch benutzen, um zum Beispiel einfach nur mal sich auf ein Ding wieder zu konzentrieren und rauszukommen aus diesem Gespringe und diesem dauernden Abgelenke und diesem, jetzt ist ja schon so lange Ding, sondern einfach wieder in den Flow zu kommen. Und insofern bin ich da tatsächlich nicht pessimistisch, was das angeht, sondern ich glaube eher, dass es so eine Zwischenphase ist, zwar weil wir uns alle mal ins Internet gewöhnen mussten, aber tatsächlich, oder zum Beispiel der Rolling Stone oder Mother Jones, die bringen immer wieder richtig lange Geschichten und die Klickzahlen darauf sind gut. Das ist nicht so, dass das halt irgendwie die das nur machen, weil sie sich dazu verpflichtet fühlen, sondern die machen es tatsächlich auch, weil sie eben tatsächlich damit auch viele Leser kriegen so.
Ja, das mag aber auch, es gibt da noch ein Problem. Du kannst einfacher irgendeinem Politiker irgendwas ans Bein binden oder jetzt kannst du sagen, ach ja der Verfassungsschutz, der ist alles blöd, Männer sind sie natürlich. Aber das ist relativ einfach im Moment. Aber über das Thema, über was wir heute Abend gesprochen haben, da geht es erstens um richtig Big Crime und zweitens, und das ist viel, viel schlimmer, geht es um ganz viel Geld. Hier sind Großunternehmen mit beteiligt. Es geht ja nicht nur um die Regierung, sondern es geht auch, dahinter stecken ja immer die Firmen. Wir haben angefangen, wie komme ich an diese ganze Geschichte? Am Anfang standen die 14 verschwundenen Betriebsräte von Mercedes-Benz in Argentinien. Und da geht es auch um Geld. Die haben das nicht gemacht, weil sie so Sardisten oder so Mordlüstern waren, sondern weil sie ihre Produktivität erhöhen wollten. Und das hat ja auch funktioniert damals. Und jetzt, wir sind ja jetzt im obersten Gerichtshof der USA angelangt. Die werden jetzt über die Zulässigkeit dieser Klage entscheiden. Ich frage dich mal zurück, wer hat in der Bundesrepublik angesichts dieser Größenordnung, dass dieser Fall in den USA vom obersten Gerichtshof jetzt verhandelt wird? Und das Verfahren ist anhängig. Wir hatten darüber berichtet.
Niemand.
In den USA aber auch nicht viel mehr. Und in Argentinien auch nicht viel mehr. Und da ist das Thema Menschenrechte, das ist ein Thema. Überall da, wo du wirtschaftliche Interessen angehst, da werden die Leute so klein.
Also eigentlich sollte man ja denken, dass da die öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien genau diese Lücke führen, die wir in unserem Gespräch mit dem Herrn Döpfner hatten. Unter anderem genau diese Frage, wie denn das Verhältnis zu den großen Anzeigenkunden aussieht. Und die Antwort war nun alles andere als befriedigend. Die Glanz war auf der Oberfläche relativ klar, aber war am Kern halt irgendwie eher so...
Er meinte, wir haben ja intern so eine Richtlinie rausgegeben, dass es bei uns das nicht gibt, dass Anzeigenkunden Anfluss nehmen können. Aber dann fing er an, das so abzuschwächen. Ja, und am Ende meinte dann ja die Modeindustrie, die Modeberichterstattung sei ja völlig verloren. Ich hab da nicht mehr die Zeit gehabt zu fragen, ob auch Bild der Frau gemeint ist, aber im Wesentlichen war das eine Bankrotterklärung, fand ich. Na klar, ist ja auch so. Das war ja im Grunde jedem klar, wir wollten es nur mal hören. Aber wer soll denn das überhaupt machen können, wenn die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen... Das gilt ja schon als lang im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen Nonfunk, wenn du da mal eine 45-Minuten-Sendung machen kannst.
Ja, die ganzen Sender werden ja entwortet, heißt das.
Was?
Erzähl mal. Ja, das ist eine Entwortung. Die großen Feature-Geschichten macht ja kaum noch jemand.
Eigentlich nur noch Deutschland Radio, ne?
Ja, dann gibt es riesige Co-Produktionen, da sind dann irgendwie fünf Produktionen im Jahr. Davon kannst du nicht mehr leben. Und davon kannst du auch keine Recherche mehr bezahlen. Und ich meine, im Hörfunk geht noch einiges. Aber das Fernsehen, ich möchte, glaube ich, darüber die Aussage verweigern.
Ja, da brauchen wir, glaube ich, nicht drüber reden. Ich fasse auch nicht, glaube ich, die Märze unserer Hörer gucken gar nicht mehr so viel Fernsehen, was ich ganz gut finde.
Ich mach keine Zeit mehr, weil sie immer unsere langen Sendungen hören.
Stimmt, genau.
Wir sind auch jetzt schon, bei was hier, zwei Stunden, 16 Minuten?
Muss unbedingt jetzt ein Glas Wein trinken.
Ja, wir sind auch eigentlich inhaltlich fast am Ende, ne?
Genau, wir sind eigentlich inhaltlich am Ende. Worüber wir nicht geredet haben, ist nun ja eigentlich der Prozess von Eichmann. Als er dann in Tel Aviv war und das ist eine Muppet-Show in diesem Buch.
Das kann ich jedem empfehlen.
Und ich glaube, das lassen wir jetzt mal als Spannungsbogen.
Unglaublich, ja. Desdorch, das Buch heißt, Eichmann wurde noch gebraucht.
Genau, und wir werden es auch verlinken. Es ist auf jeden Fall extrem spannend. Ich hätte auch noch keine Zeit, das komplett durchzulesen, aber die Sachen, die ich gelesen habe, da blieb mir teilweise echt der Mund offenstehen. Und ich kenne mich nur eigentlich ein bisschen aus mit diesen ganzen Themen. Und insofern lassen wir das mal gerade als Hausaufgabe für unsere Leser. Insbesondere dieses Kapitel über den Prozess gegen Eichmann. Und dann bleibt uns eigentlich nur, uns zu bedanken für deine Zeit.
Ne, umgekehrt.
Und wenn ihr Lust habt, wir haben da unten noch so einen Flatter-Button, auf den ihr klicken könnt, wenn ihr möchtet. Und ansonsten bedanken wir uns fürs Zuhören. Und bis zum nächsten Mal.